i'm on day one of my period so that's
going to factor into this conversation
okay okay okay i feel oh
i want to strengthen
that women only come on their periods
because i want the real shit induce
myself with where i am on my cycle
you know what i mean like i'm on day two
thank god
i did not schedule this for yesterday
because i had pms i do suffer from from
ppmd what did what it's not pms anymore
right well it is politics
syndrome well i believe if you have what
i have which is
rage disorder i think is that i have
that not on my parents i haven't had my
period in years and
that's like a 24 7 thing so i have pms
on like steroids and i've always had it
i've always become a monster for two
days a month and what is how does that
look how does that present yeah how does
that present itself
because i'm here to tell you it's
totally normal and healthy and that's
how you should act all the time well for
two days a month i try to destroy
everything that's good and that i've
worked toward and relationships they
deeply care about okay i gotta go
down to the fucking ground and
i've had that my whole since i was 12
you know where it's truly like i become
a werewolf
um can you are you conscious of it when
it's happening
yes
there's this thing just don't scream at
that well i think what i've struggled
with and i by the way just got diagnosed
like this past
2019 thank god it was right before the
pandemic and prozac treats it so
good news like there's a solution
but um for so long i just felt like oh
no these two days i'm actually more like
myself
like this is this is the real me oh that
i sort of have to push down
this is who i am the rest of the month
yeah is when my mask is on and i'm able
to kind of contain
you know when i have to present as the
socially constructed version of what a
woman should be yes
so then
like really a week before my period i
was a monster and then my period i'm
actually okay again you're seeing me on
day one okay you know so i'm bleeding
i'd be okay hemorrhaging hemorrhaging
you need a liner these are expensive no
i've moved on to menstrual cups okay
okay and we can talk about what we can
talk about
damage i knew this was going to happen i
knew that you were going to be so
relentlessly interesting and fascinating
that i wasn't going to be able to say
anything that i needed to say let me
tell you
i mean am i hosting this podcast yes now
yes anyway i will just head out to
what's happening this
[Laughter]
the menstrual cups
and people i think might have heard
about like the diva cup which was one of
the first to market which i resent i
resent the name never liked the name
never liked the name just called the
cunt i'm a grown woman yeah what are we
doing also i don't feel like a diva when
i'm jamming a plastic shot glass inside
me at the airport and here's the thing a
diva would go
i don't right exactly do that for me
a diva would never put their cup in
themselves by the way god bless my best
friend in seventh grade i was so scared
of using tampons she inserted one for me
bless her heart now if that isn't like
friendship and if she's not on megan's
law
i do not trust the fbi but i was truly
like i know all the cool girls are doing
it and i'm just too scared and she did
it for me
um
anyway
the menstrual cup i use is called a salt
cup to a salt salt and it's been a game
changer i'm not sponsored by it so just
know but like it is i do talk about it a
lot because i'm obsessed with it and
you
insert the cup this is
fyi you're in real time watching a
business woman
take an opportunity to get a paid
partnership and
it happens
i respect it she was in the car
you know if i'm a brand ambassador then
i am but i'm just speaking my truth it
just means it's like organic so you
insert it
and you leave it set it and forget it
for eight to 12 hours
that might be wrong
maybe just eight so what happens when
you definitely pushed it yeah you just
booked it and then you lost it um we'll
cut it out uh wait so
how do you pee
okay this is gonna be an anatomy lesson
wait a second
hold on
so what if where does the sperm go
okay i know
okay i
i know how vaginas work okay
i know i i missed that magic school bus
episode i think it got pulled
no but the diva cup doesn't it go into
your entire vagina okay because i know
that tampons go to a different place
than where the tea comes out exactly and
this functions the same way it's going
to the same stuff
so this is a tiny cup
i mean i kind of want to take it out and
show you i won't but it's um i might
need you to pull up okay
okay i don't want to fuck up my
algorithm but okay fine it's like it's
like this big okay but it it folds so
you fold it in you stick it up sort of
like got it okay and then it expands i'm
sorry it blossoms it blossoms it blooms
inside the flower okay okay so okay it
compresses i see it yeah saalt
yeah and then it catches all the blood
and then my blood because i i take a um
i'm on birth control i'm in a different
one now but i used to do one where i
only had my period like every three or
four months or something and the blood
comes out like when i say black tar i
mean a viscous get it this time
like um it looks like engine fluid it
looks like haggis
because it
is it haggis no blood i i yes i
understand and by the way that's
concerning so i've been i i'm not
concerned i feel great i feel great
about it so i have been told because
i've been on a journey with my hormones
that it shouldn't look like that turns
out because mine did too okay um turns
out that's that's a problem but well
[Music]
you want it i have 99 problems and i
can't
my pussy i just can't take on my
menstrual blood do with this what you
will but it's just coagulating and
properly
i i can't there have been times where
i'm like did a small organ fall out i
don't like that it doesn't feel it was
that bad
[Applause]
that was a miscarriage from the 90s
that was a suppository that never
absorbed
[Music]
oh my god
same sink it was a fossilized abortion
yes they didn't vacuum it all out but
just understand that the way the period
cup functions is it catches it
okay
it holds on to it and especially for
those of us who have a heavier flow
um it catches
it catches way more than you think it
will like i think we assume we'd fill up
like liters full of menstrual blood
right not really true okay right
we're not really bleeding that much even
if we think of ourselves as having a
heavy flow anyway you set it and forget
it i believe it reduces cramping again
i'm open for sponsorships
i'm happy to my doll
tranquilizers
betterhelp.com yes
suitcase feels like a lot of things
would fit this straight jackets
incorporated
so anyway this the cups have really
helped prozac really helps for ppmd
um and yeah at 40 years old i have now
started to
really just now in the last year figure
out like how to have a period well i
just figured out where the vagina goes
so
have a little behind you i mean i want
you to leave that in but i'm also scared
that you will
you said how do you pee well i just said
how do you pee i didn't realize that the
cup collapses
into the um circumference of a tampon
and then can fit
okay yeah okay i was just worried the p
went into the cup the p doesn't go into
the cup got it he doesn't go because p
comes out of your butt
wow we got it
okay when you do the sex talk with your
kids can i come
i feel like i didn't get i watched
blossom i thought i got it i didn't get
it by the way there is a part of me as i
get older and older when i realize
there's gaps of information i don't have
correct no no i'm sorry
so much so
that up until
five six years ago i thought on
thanksgiving the pilgrims and the
natives had a wonderful meal oh yeah me
too together i mean that was sure yeah
well all of our history books were wrong
we thought they fairly exchanged
blankets for land and that it was a uh
we dressed up in second grade and
reenacted yes we did but we did yes yeah
absolutely i mean i really have an
interest in being sent away for
like a week into an adult camp
where i can just fill in some gaps in
some gaps you know what i mean like i do
feel like i i was very blessed with an
incredibly loving childhood and a really
wonderful childhood but certain things
fell away so i
uh
am willing to embarrass myself yet again
um
my brand
i have fake boobs and i had to get a
mammogram right and there's you have to
do um i think a sonogram to whatever
make sure because you can't really feel
under there whatever
and i had a i've had a pain in my chest
that's like a darting pain i went to my
rheumatologist and i was like i i think
there's something wrong with my heart i
think i have like a heart issue
and it like hurts really bad right here
and he just took his hand and went it's
over here
i was like no pledge of allegiance to
the flag over your heart he was like
it's right over here it's like all right
yeah it's like yeah that's just scar
tissue honey
it's both good news and bad news really
you know there is a there's other you
know things that are are wrong clearly
but talking about menstrual blood this
does bring me to a connection that we
have and then i will i do want to do a
mini monologue about how important
you've been in my life
but
first we used to go to the same
gynecologist
yes we did and real quick so the
gynecologist yes
i remember because everyone goes you
look like june i get it all the time i'm
doing a gynological exam with our shared
guy in college at this time you look so
much like june field
so i think our vaginas are very similar
also i mean i do feel like that's a
compliment to you thank you i have i
mean cut cut
but i
it's not a compliment to you keep it
keep it not a compliment to you because
she delivered the news to me that i i
don't get delivered babies i get
delivered news um that i got a
hemorrhoid from doing a clot a pilates
class called bar method oh no and then i
had a deflated hemorrhoid so hopefully
our vaginas don't look too much alone
listen i've only had one hemorrhoid in
my life and it was one of those things
sort of like heartburn like you hear
people talking about it and you're like
oh that sounds really bad no idea what
it is i haven't had it
and i've heard people complain about
hemorrhoids and i went during the
pandemic from not working out at all to
doing like an insane lifting program
okay and gave myself a hemorrhoid
and it was one of the most painful
experiences i've ever because you have
to sit on a hat yeah so just like
justice for hemorrhoid habits like it's
hard you can before you have kids you
can get your hemorrhoids uh or your the
nerves in your butthole or whatever
rubber banded
come on oh we know
again we know many people that have had
this
rubber band so that when you're pushing
you don't
i assume that that's the logic as
someone that knows uh whose knowledge is
boundless about the female anatomy i'm
just going to google it just to make
sure my science is right here
rubber band hemorrhoids so that it does
so they don't explode rubber band
litigation for hemorrhoids okay yes
rubber band little gate
ligament ligation this is not lit it's
not a legal matter
[Laughter]
okay
so your butthole can't sue so the
butthole uh cannot sue
i don't think there's any tort involved
rubber band ligation is a procedure in
which hemorrhoid is tied off at its base
with rubber bands cutting off the blood
flow to the hemorrhoid this treatment is
only for internal hemorrhoids to do this
procedure a doctor inserts a viewing
instrument
his penis uh into the anus
the hemorrhoid is grasped with an
instrument and a device places a rubber
band around the base of the hemorrhoid
the hemorrhoid then shrinks and dies and
in about a week falls off
wow
okay wish i had known i have a friend
who you know who had after childbirth a
huge hemorrhoid
and she sat on her new sofa
and it exploded and she said it was
bright red blood like the color like a
blood the color
has become depressed from being in the
comedy community she's not in it hers is
fresh and red and like just yeah bright
as a daisy it exploded and she was like
it was like a neon like hemorrhoid oh my
god blood is a different shade of bread
i don't ever want to know that again i
want to forget i'm going to tell you one
more thing you're going to want to
forget our joint gynecologist at the
time also gave me a little the reason i
kept going to her
and i still kind of dabble in her
because she will give me the gossip she
will give me the gynological gossip and
she will tell you some shit that is
absolutely violating many a hippocratic
oath she said um because you know when
you're like gonna go on a vacation and
you don't want to have a period on your
vacation it always happens right like
you're going on the trip in two days and
then you just start it she said to me
she was like if you need to get your
period done faster yeah put in a tampon
if you need the dates to move
[Laughter]
you need some flex dates
we need to reschedule your period
basically we just need to like we need
to turn the blackout dates in we need to
turn five days into two
and she said put in a tampon sit in the
bathtub for five minutes take the tampon
out put another tampon in sit in the
bathtub for five minutes and keep
repeating it until there's no blood left
wait a second why aren't we all doing
this and why haven't we all been doing
this this is the best hack i've ever
heard concur
but aren't i doing that with my cup
no the pee gets it all out
no the pee fucks it up
no because what it does is it it
essentially
cleans it like it grabs the your blood
right now is just falling out when it
decides to fall out like this well just
because we know
how like sticky and it is
tar ask it is yeah this will grab it wet
it
and it turns more like
what it should look like that liquid
blood and then you scoop it out you like
um what's the thing it's not exfoliating
it's like exfoliating your uterus
i'm wicking is that the word
john wicking just getting that pussy wet
wow
wicked and then it comes out
faster and then she also told me that
because i
i have the water soaking in yes because
you're in it and then the water i didn't
entirely realize that you had to sit in
water in the bathtub i just for some
reason
heard that you had
that job
we just want to make it as creepy as
possible so just do it as a bit
empty bathtub box of tampons and start
you can like like have your english
patient fantasy should you want to
okay so the water so the water you're in
a uh now that's with water
sense that was an important thing
so it gets wet
expands
grabs the blood on the side and pulls it
out and you just keep doing it until
there's none left and then you do it
like the next day because there'll be
like more that falls or something
and it's like a game changer wow is this
a medical podcast
um i went to university of phoenix
online and i
did this all sounds like i haven't
logged in
i can't remember the past i signed up
but um i think it's going i think it's
great i think it's going i think it's
great for the world
and then another thing she told me is
that because i
had everything lasered my like my shirt
first time i got paid that's not health
insurance not like i'm lazy
all those bills and collections sure
it's like i need to shave my pussy
because that's how i'm gonna get the
money to pay off honestly a wise
investment i've got no problems with
that no notes then as you get older
you're sort of like how can it this
feels weird now it feels now if a guy is
attracted to me with no pubic hair i
think he's a weirdo yeah he's a
pedophile i have now put myself in a
situation where only pedophiles are
interested in me and that feels like a
red flag but i'm sorry because i'm gonna
ask i'm gonna ask a question and you
know what i'm not afraid to ask okay
don't i thought that when even if you
lasered a lot
that the hair would always continue to
grow back at some point i got chemo
the idea when you just realized like oh
that wasn't the procedure i thought it
was
yes i did it
seven times
over two years
and that's how you really kill the
follicle right that's the goal but
here's what i'll say
hairs do still grow okay uh never the
texture no it's working smithers
smithers like smithers one yes baby
they're my they're
[Applause]
flying it's like a rat tail i made this
decision before i had like standards or
like knew what a red flag was or knew
like i don't want to attract the wrong
kind of person whatever now only guys
that like where von dutch want to date
me whatever yeah and so it's like one
chain wallet after another and um
and she said she goes oh honey it's no
problem one of my biggest requests right
now is
pubic hair plugs
no no plugs
and i was like
coming in no i can't afford this
doctor's appointment but i'm gonna get
everything out of it and
she said that so many and this actually
made me
less of a made me love men okay in a way
because so many guys were going like
can you please have pubic hair like this
is weird and so girls were coming in
going i lasered everything off but the
guy i'm with wants pubes so what do i do
and so they're it's not a merkin
i think the technology's a little ahead
of that they are plugs
i mean i guess i'm just like are we
still caught in this cycle of like
wanting them on or off based on what the
men in our lives prefer like
i mean
here's what i'll say here back if i want
a guy to shave his balls i he should
actually a hundred percent agree i guess
my question is
whose hair is it
is it your own from your head
no but that is the eye you know the
eyebrow procedure no i have a friend
okay i have a friend so i've never had a
problem growing eyebrow i mean i have a
giant unibrow okay okay it's like
sunglasses if i let it go and
but i have a friend who has a very hard
time growing in eyebrows they're very
slight they're very small and not it
takes they have to pen them in yeah for
jobs and it's like it's like that's her
problem right like we're i'm like
stuffing my bra getting fake tips like i
know i'm like everything about you is so
perfect your biggest problem is that you
have to draw your eyebrows in and it's a
hassle must be nice and the procedure is
they take strips of hair from the back
of your head your scalp and they implant
it in the shape of an eyebrow above your
head or your eyes
but
the only
curveball really catch is that
those follicles grow like hair
so if she's on a two week vacation and
forgets her little trimmers it starts to
grow like hair
no yeah eyebrow hair knows to stop at a
certain point yeah it's got it's it's
understood its own assignment yeah no it
knows it knows that it came prepared
whereas this will grow like human hair
and what you probably don't want to do
is tweeze it because
that's the follicle right well i don't
know you know she has to cut it you have
to she has to cut it yes yes
trim it yeah just stay on it yes correct
wow obsessed well i imagine that those
pubes pube transplants i mean i'm
thinking i would prefer it was my own
hair not someone else's but the hair on
your head would look insane on your
pussy it has to be someone's pubes
they're different textures no no no
you're saying she's taking someone
else's looks like liquid gold are you
telling me you're gonna put this on your
pussy and a wig
well i'd prefer my own am i gonna take
someone else's pubes and sew them into
my vagina your
vagina cannot look like brooklyn decker
i won't have it you can't have this hair
on your pussy wow so they're taking
someone else's pubic hair so we could in
this moment donate our own pubes i don't
have any i don't know
i'd love to so push came to shove and
like you needed a couple bucks came to
shop
by the way i'm seeing pubes everywhere
i'm starting a business i'm going on
shark tank without you because you're a
hater and i will start this business
with honestly
well i'm just upset for you like if push
came to shove like you couldn't donate
your pubes like that's not available
you know i've never been in a jail i've
never been in that jam
where it's like oh my god like i could
solve this problem but i only had pubes
okay well that's to donate not all of us
you know all of us aren't that lucky
for you i mean it's also here's what's
good for you here's what i'll say
putting other people's hair on our heads
way grosser to me
really near your mouth it's near your
eyes you would take someone else's pussy
hair and sew it into most pussy hairs
not near the web part the up top part
i don't trust your geography
okay when it comes to the female body i
don't know i would say i would like to
purchase some of your pubes but from the
northernmost
region
of york it's like a wine like you want
like the tuscany yes
i want the hair that's kind of on the
inside of the legs and on the top the
border the border the border
i need those border pupils yes
the ones that have not been come down
yeah
or any or peed on
but then again what
who knows you know i'm not gonna fight
this anymore i realize i am i can just
surrender sort of a rabbit hole you're
not gonna find your way yeah rabbit hair
i gotta go
that's the name of the business rabbit
hole we get rabid hair from rabbit's
foot key chains and we just staple it
under your pussy
i do think though this isn't this is a
good thing
that you and i came up in a time where
we we thought that that was what we had
to do and some of us made very permanent
decisions yes a very permanent decision
really quick i want to get to because
we're going to go on a million tangents
and that's what a podcast is but i do
want i i will not miss the opportunity
to tell the audience
that june
number one you gave me the best advice
i've ever gotten in my life
number two doesn't sound right it
doesn't sound like me got me you it was
an accident i don't know i don't think
you knew what you were doing you were
not um you also uh got me through my
dad's funeral
whitney that's you don't know how though
i don't number three
you
i largely credit for why i decided to
start writing and creating my own things
what 100
that's absurd
do you know any of what i'm talking
about i i really don't you've just like
accidentally changed my life many many
times and you taught me
about a concept that i like to call
like you know there's the the the what's
the good the good witch what's the other
witch
the bad and the bad wish okay good okay
what's the opposite of good
sorry uh wicked witch which um
uh are their vaginas are in different
places that's that's right
so i also am into the good bitch in the
bad bitch
and
you and i i feel like are both people
that are willing to go like you guys
might think i'm a bitch right now but
yeah i someone needs to say it sure and
i heard a story about how you were on a
movie
and it was someone else's production
obviously and you claimed your space
because you needed time to like because
sometimes when you're on a movie or
someone else's show they force you to do
a
job that you're not proud of because
simply you don't have the time and
something is switched
and then to have to go can i have a
second to just learn the new lines and
then we'll you know but we all want to
pretend that like we don't need to work
on stuff this doesn't take any work well
it's interesting because i do think
that's taken practice but i i also think
on
i mean i'm curious how you feel about it
whitney but it when you're acting it's
it's such
it's vulnerable work yeah it's emotional
work it should be
and
i do think most sets are technical
mediums yes and the crew gets their time
and all the technicians get their time
to do their thing and yet actors are
expected to like start at action and
then with a brand new script that just
came out and then this was recast and oh
now i'm in a bathing suit instead of
like it's just like absolutely you threw
all these new things at me
absolutely yeah but you're an improviser
oh that's not
it yeah because otherwise other people's
lines aren't changing you can't
improvise if other people's lines are
stuck and i also think that when
you know we were coming up for so long
in an industry that makes you feel
poverty stricken and that you should
just be so grateful to be there you
should be so grateful to get anything
you should be so lucky you should be so
lucky and so this is it you get to do
the thing like isn't it wonderful and i
love being on set like when people are
complaining about hours and stuff i'm
like i would be here all day
love love love love love it
but i'm also like
this is
we're creating something here and yeah
conditions are important
you know what i mean and like needs are
important and
i'm also of the mind where ah
i i really believe in safe respectful
work spaces and
i also believe that art i don't in safe
respectful well-lit workplaces well-lit
and by respectful i mean well live but i
also believe that like actors are
artists
well here's what drives me nuts it
drives me nuts
that you know is as as the person that
the pressure is all on and i have and
you have to deliver but like
we're the only people that if we ask for
more time or more rehearsal
are thought of as divas and bitches and
whatever but it's like old news but i'm
gonna save you so much time in post if
you just let me learn this continuity
now like my whole thing is thank me
later and i have had to build sort of
the uh
uh the ability to tolerate the
discomfort of others and you know what
you're not gonna like me for the next
two days but you are gonna fucking love
me when you're sitting in post for the
next three months because i had a second
to get my shit together and when
everyone asked like what's what do you
want your writer what do you need on set
i'm like time rehearsal time i would
just love to be able to rehearse this a
couple i'd like to know where the
cameras are
i'd like to know is this a single is
this a wide like i just that i would i
would like information and the other
thing is that i mean i'm still working
toward this i haven't gotten there but i
felt it a few times is like i'm really
trying to divorce myself from
trying to be right
you know trying to like look at the
showrunner the director and like figure
out if it was okay and like look to see
if it was okay like it i want to fail
more
you know what i mean and in order to
have that kind of brave
space
you need to you need your space
you know where it's like i'm not looking
for you to move on actually i'm not
looking for this take to be perfect
right i'm looking to find something in
this scene
and that i think for women especially
like you really have to put aside your
need for like teacher say that idea
which is already please like me which is
annie ackerman the great andy ackerman
that directed all the episodes of the
the sitcom i did he did he was um he
didn't direct my episode every sign fell
yes i did yes he did sure yes which
we'll get to um uh
obsessed and he said to me because i was
very needy for approval i was very like
was that good was that funny because
without an audience there was a second
where
i would do a take of like a single
camera show or a multicam without an
audience and i was like because i had
outsourced all my self-esteem to these
sort of anonymous noises
and i would do the take and he'd be like
all right moving on i'm like was that
was that good to do like like then he's
like we're moving on
that's the answer and i was yeah
and he's so for me to say did you like
that is insulting to him right because
he's not going to move on till we get it
you know and then i would then i learned
how annoying
i was doing that because then we would
cast actors to come on the show you know
you audition 300 people and when the
person that gets it they show up and
like was that good it's like we picked
you right we could have picked anyone
and then i'm like oh my god that is so
people pleasing is a form of assholery
it's yes your low self-esteem is a
hassle yes but i will only say this
because i i do that sometimes depending
on what i'm part it is or whatever but
there have been times where i'm like
director whoever you are camera person
sound person i'm going to ask you if
that was funny right right right right
and
you're going to have to answer me yep
and i'm actually going to say that
you're lying and i don't believe it yeah
yeah and that's part of the process and
then also guess what
everyone just wants to get home if it's
not their show and i get that everyone's
got kids so when you're like valerie
cherish saying one more take i always
feel like that in the comeback when i'm
like can i just take that again but my
new thing is i request can we just do
two takes
no no just two in a row of it because i
know i'm gonna have my next one
and after i get this one i'll feel good
about it and then i'll be able to do
whatever the fuck i want and really be
free and that's usually the one
i have to tell you i did uh
i did a show called animal practice on
nbc i know you know the show oh oh i
know i know the show i know the show uh
i remember uh you
having trouble competing for screen time
with a ostrich or was it a giraffe well
i worked
alongside um an ostrich and also
okay as a co-star and they brought that
ostrich out with a bag over its head
um
and they introduced me totally i wish
they'd do with us
i mean honestly i have to put them on
the back they literally just put my own
bag over my head
and this person came out and they were
like i'm i'm the ostrich trainer and i
was like are you like
possible yeah no it's not no and that's
fine if it was jeremy hitler if it was
you're the suicidal maniac you drove an
ostrich here from texas yes you're the
guy that put the ostrich in the suitcase
and now has to it's not trained if it
has to have a bag over time all the time
exactly until they roll and we take it
off and we're all instructed to just
jump into a hallway if things go
sideways and things went sideways very
frequently oh yeah
but i had a scene where
i had to
comment like i had two lines and i had
to in the middle of a scene i sort of
hop into a doorway say oh i think it was
even one line say a line and then hop
out
and to me that's my worst nightmare like
when i'm just coming in for a quick joke
and have to leave too much pressure to
make it funny yeah
so i do it once and by the way you're
waiting oh behind a would it be you're
waiting behind a wall
like a psycho like trying to listen for
your line there's someone that's
supposed to cue you who's oh timing
[Music]
don't go don't go and then you're just
like
that's what i said or whatever fucking
thing they think is going to be funny
yeah i do it once i do it twice and the
director's like okay moving on and i'm
like oh god it felt horrible is it a
wide shot with the why can't it just be
a single so it was a single i'm not tied
to the monkey this was the scene of the
monkey okay this is the scene with
crystal the monkey who many of your
listeners might know from the hangover
more famous than all of you oh yeah
she's going to have an enormous career
um
so i am speaking to justin kirk and
crystal the monkey and and yes speaking
to crystal yes of course okay so that's
part of my line and i do it once i do it
twice i'm like i felt like a robot the
whole time like i have to
i got to get this out of my body i mean
there's definitely a primal fear being
overtaken of like this thing could bite
my face off at any moment yeah that's a
part of it um it's a primate yes so i
say to the director i'm like
can you just roll we're set up we're lit
and i'm gonna come and i'm gonna do a
series dude a couple times and he's like
ooh we
don't have the time now i'm a guest star
by the time we finish this conversation
we couldn't we could have done it if we
by the time we talked about it we're not
shooting on film buddy could have done
it like just roll yeah this i could have
done it three more times if i get this
so you get to have the credit absolutely
you get the credit if i'm funny so he
says no
and i'm in a place where i'm like okay
but i'm upset and angry and i'm like
fuck this is the thing about acting like
it's not a play like that was it the
cameras are moving like that was it
and then they turn around on crystal the
monkey
okay
and i'm watching
and crystal the monkey they just set her
up and like a locked off single
and they're at video village dying the
writers are like
dating each other just like this is so
funny and just like keep on rolling
let's see
let her play she knows what she's gonna
come up with and i am like are you
fucking kidding me
it was such a dark pivotal moment where
i was like i will never
let them cut again until i feel like
i've risked something of myself
i've like humiliated myself a little bit
i've left something here or also i leave
knowing it's all on the floor
it's all on the floor leaving knowing
you have better
choices in you or better takes in you
the worst and it's also guess what if i
say
roll on me again i'm gonna make your
show better i don't get paid that much
on this is my show you're the one that
get the ones that get benefit if i'm
funny you're paying me way less than i
deserve so the monkey is higher on the
call sheet than me well of course i mean
i actually think one of crystal's
requests was only let june have two
takes and that's right and that yeah it
was a weird thing that was in crystal's
rider um but
then fire me and find someone that's
that totally finds like i shouldn't be
on this show if i'm gonna be on the
bench like this or if you don't respect
the fact that don't hire me if you don't
think i have good gut instincts about my
choices
totally like just hire someone else hire
someone that will just go like
do shitty takes then feel fine about it
yes yes hire someone with a lower bar i
also feel like i have i do want to find
i want to work with a director who i i
feel like i can you you hear of those
performances where people are like oh i
just gave myself over completely to the
director
you know i've never had that but i i do
want to have that but i think a large
part of it is also i've mostly worked
with male directors
you know and there is that thing of like
you're in a space
which is i mean i remember talking to
eliza jones about this like you're in a
space trying to act where you're
surrounded by men
you know and
it's you're burying yourself yeah
sometimes physically sometimes just
emotionally emotionally it's harder but
there's also a lot of
i can't speak for everyone i can't even
speak for my generation but i tend to go
there which is
i used to
um when i went to this trainer
i used to always ask him to pair me
because it was only four people working
out at a time with a trainer and like
bradley cooper worked out
you know exactly where i'm going yes oh
right oh bless her heart yeah i always
leave a place and don't tell her yeah
and then she stays
you're like way off it and i know you
were with a dermatologist i remember
texting you like oh wow
he's so great
or like i that was yesterday's news
casey's next in line and then i'm after
casey
okay well then we just need a more
seventh generation adopter of your you
know but usually
we should be more connected because we
have the same face so you should know
i mean we should
be of all people i feel like we should
be connecting more than anyone it's so
true so just like think of me when
you're ready to leave someone when
you're finding something new like i'm
just think of me kindly to you that you
might not like okay
which is
and i'll tell everyone why all the ways
you've changed my life yeah i do want to
get back to that you come off to me the
way i think other people accuse me of
coming off as so a lot of people are
like you're so busy i never want to
bother you
you i believe are the person people
think i am in terms of how busy you are
so here's the thing i do i do
i do think there's like
and i hope i don't my friend works at
your company i mean i do yeah we need to
talk about dory howard the best the best
woman we both know better than both of
us and frankly frankly we have been
taken on as charity cases i'm like from
make a wish kid i mean it is the fact
that she's even my friend is just you
know she's just they don't make them
like that she's my i mean she parented
me
yeah raised me at 22. she paid my
outstanding parking tickets
she paid i believe it yeah uh
i've seen her do things and here's the
thing about the way she helps it's
without any judgment it's without any
judgment and she doesn't
she just doesn't advertise it and you
know what else it is she accepts you at
where you are
so she doesn't have the projecting
emotional perfectionism that a lot of us
have which is that i'm really strong in
this area why aren't you she just goes
oh this is what you're good at this is
what you're not good at i'm going to
come to this person for this and then
what you are good at i'll come to you
for that yeah so in our friend circle
look
this is a story that still hurts me a
little bit but now i look back and i'm
kind of grateful it was an email chain
with me dory our other best friend ginny
and jenny's mom i want to say okay and
this was at the time when maybe it was a
blackberry maybe it was a sidekick i
don't know but in the email if you had
programmed someone in your phone as ice
in case of emergency it would come up
okay june diane ice ice right
uh
grace weiss and nothing not ice yes
emily noonan ice like you wouldn't know
everyone would know who in your contacts
was that i'm so worried we're on this
email chain and i'm like
how come everyone has ice by their names
except me
i'm like what is this i mean i'm 20 free
and i call dory and i'm like what's ice
like how come i what's what is going on
with your phones i think you have a bug
and she was like whitney
you are not the first person i would go
to
in an emergency
but you have other things where i would
come to you first right it's just safety
or
needing
anything is not what i mean i'm one of
them
but then i did she knows that i am good
in a very dramatic saga like kids need
to be rescued yes i she comes to me for
that
like it's so interesting that's
fascinating because i actually told
casey i had an event happen with
someone i know where they made an ask of
me that was inappropriate and
disturbing and i was like god and they
were down on their luck for sure and i
felt really badly about that but i was
also like oh that's what it changes the
course of our relationship the fact that
you think that this is okay yeah um
which by the way is part of the growing
up cleansing process where it's like you
show me who you are now i just have to
listen and have compassion and now we're
just going to change our proximity
that's right and the answer is no unless
you're wrong you know yes and the answer
is no but i was talking to casey about
it and by saying yes
i'm hurting you because i'm enabling you
yes absolutely but i was like there's
you know where do you have to be in your
life is this about me asking you to do
my podcast
wildly inappropriate segment
i didn't know how to get there it was a
certainly a roundabout way and i came to
tell you you know you should never done
that i want to do this on camera to hold
you accountable okay on day one of my
period it was wildly inappropriate
i'm sorry i'm interrupting you so no so
i was saying to casey i'm like i also
don't know this person that well and i
was like that's
what shocks me so much that like they're
in this position and they're asking me
for this and i don't know them well
enough was it money okay yes a shocking
amount but i i did say to her i'm like
you know there are only a couple of
people in my life if i really was in a
tough spot that i would go to and ask
and we talked about who those people
were and you were one of them
so you may not have been ice then
but i think you've turned into ice i've
turned into ice i'm now i'm ice clean
because i do count you as and here's the
thing about people like sometimes i i
think our culture
we're and i know i'm bad with texts i'm
bad with emails i don't stay in touch as
much as people would but let me tell you
something about that it inspire even
when that happens it inspires me because
i'm like i know there's no love lost i
know she is i know she's not going fuck
whitney i know she's busy and she's
taking care of herself and she's not
allowing her friendship to become toxic
by making me an obligation like for you
to respond when you don't have time
that is not true friendship that's
codependence well and also i genuinely
do have trouble with i just picture you
laughing hysterically like like wendy's
the best and then you're talking about
how much you love me so you forgot to
text me so here's what actually happens
is that yes
yes in the moment i'm like hahaha or
whatever i'm feeling and thinking like
oh my god i want to see her or you
basically only respond if it's a picture
of oprah i know or a meme of oprah sure
but i also have trouble with screens i
trouble with that screen i have trouble
with this screen i have trouble with you
on your phone right now no i'm looking
at our text
to be fair the last two texts i sent you
were just green bubbles with no text
so to be fair
there's not a lot to respond i'm not
giving you a lot we're getting to the
bottom of it actually but sometimes
texts come up and i experience them with
joy and then they seem to go they get
out of my grasp sure sure do you know
what i mean like an email if an email
hits my inbox i know i'm sitting down
at certain times of the day to get at my
emails and then you said i said math
where you got married let me tell you
something on june 13 2019 i wrote mass
where you got married no response it was
a google away
it was a google i hate
i do not respond to texts if it's
something you can google and i never
responded to that well
on june 29th a fucking read i'm getting
on june 20th you wrote horrified i'm
answering this text two weeks late yeah
santa barbara museum of history but not
sure if it's still there
and i'm not
i mean
excellent okay
and i know there's group texts that
we've been on that i haven't responded
to
i love it i love it i have not a
question
really i hope not because i also do
think that we live in a culture that
requires us to all be in touch and
there's something about and i think this
has actually to do with grief i've
experienced where i feel i'm at a point
in my life where i can accept being
separate from someone
and still feeling connected to them
and do you know what i mean yes do we
all have to be so connected here all the
time to feel like connected to someone
no because we are well you and i you and
i i mean you and casey obviously knew
each other before me and we're already
doing road hard and put away by the time
but i feel like we have been through
it's like when people like soldiers from
a war meet and they're like i
your family yeah i don't have to know
what you have for breakfast this morning
i don't even have to know your kid's
name but we are so close
and there's no small talk always just go
straight to big talk i mean you when i
have a fucking
real big problem
i go to you i hope i'm ice the last
you're not iced i shouldn't be i don't
because i don't know how to do that yeah
um
uh and that ship has sailed in terms of
me ever when i hurt myself i just put it
on instagram um and then hope someone
comes
so i was in a really tough situation
with someone that had mean girled me
really hard
and you wrote in all caps do not defend
yourself period
could not have gotten better that's not
the best advice i've ever gotten from
you but i'll tell you that a second but
it was like it's like when you come in
you come in hard
in a way that is more impactful
than a once a month
nothing text
well i appreciate that i'm glad about
that
um and i think if there's a level of
respect this is possible when insecurity
exists like let's get a coffee let's
it's like or just facetiming what do you
need yeah what just catch up for what
for what who has that i kind of look
no look at my story
it's going to be monetized yeah did you
mute me what are we doing right we're
gonna put some ads on it yeah let's do
like yeah come in get famous and come do
my podcast and we'll talk
we're now taking a break from me yapping
it up with my good friend june just two
geeses cocking
to talk about daily harvest because like
june
daily harvest is good for you
emily wrote that in fact it's all we
stock in our company fridge that's
actually a true fact
take a look and
tell tell me i'm lying daily harvest
delivers delicious harvest bowls
flatbreads smoothies and more and we now
stop this ad for benching to do an
impression of a
flatbread now emily will do an
impression of a smoothie
going up the straw amiibo
and as a comedy duo they will now show
you their interpretation
of a harvest bowl
anything else
are you not entertained
sitting the first time i've been asked
to impersonate food
daily harvest is delicious food it's all
built on whole organic fruits and
vegetables that conveniently stay fresh
fresh fresh in your freezer i just move
over the body parts and i put daily
harvest right in there snug as a bug
always ready when you are it really is
the whole package back to you emily get
more time back to do you and take care
of yourself this summer go to
dailyharvest.com good for you to get up
to 40 dollars off your first box that's
dailyharvest.com good for you for up to
40 off your first box
dailyharvest.com good for you so this is
a box from stitch fix okay so
i have there's a rumor going around that
who started it the way that i buy my
clothes is childish and immature and uh
downright uh career sabotaging it's
upsetting to people
uh it's it's weird you're confusing
rumors with facts
this is how i shop for clothes i'm not
great at it i don't have great instincts
i just go on like like
thrift store websites and buy things
this is what an average day of
deliveries in our household looks like
let's see what i got oh oh a parcel and
a parcel is it a top
is it beef jerky
is it a pair of shoes
is it a letter from the war
this is a vintage bathing suit that i
bought to wear as a top with jeans
what is that this is a bathing suit
is that vintage because it looks like
it's from uh
uh oriental express what's that magazine
um monthly
nothing fit
okay i'm sorry that i'm not a
professional stylist
this is from hackberryville mcallen
texas apartment one you cutting into
clothes with scissors is nerve-racking i
get my clothes uh from apartments
i mean it's pretty good
[Music]
are you still interviewing tony hawk
do you guys know
emily i don't want you uh getting it
wait the fact that you're wearing an 85
shirt from uh from an la street carny is
uh
did you guys know that stitchfix offers
hand selected expert design hand
selecting i'm hand selecting these right
now
stitch mix offers clothing's hand
selected by expert stylus for your
unique size style and budget it's a
completely different and fun way to find
clothes that you will love to wear every
piece is chosen for your fit and your
life and it's the easy solution to
finding what makes you look and feel
your best
but but what what if this is your life
are you implying this isn't easy there's
no subscription required try stitch fix
once or set up automatic deliveries
instead of this
i mean as long as you will let us wear
these light up cowboy hats with whatever
chic
uh sheep designs you send no sheep chic
she they send chic clothing oh so
new me new year new me
a professional stylist picked these out
and bent and you took the quiz for me
because i was worried i have a very
specific style like i don't like you
know i'm very specific with what i like
look at the stuff they sent i was
freaking out they set this up which i
never would have bought on my own at
first i was like oh it's black i have
enough black no no stitch fix stitch fix
always has something up their sleeve pun
intended
look at this little shoulder pop out oh
a black it's got yes but it's got look
it's got a little shoulder to get your
booster shot i love that
you're missing the the what's going on
with this shirt hold on look how cute
this is
um wait oh hold on
it's a shirt and a shirt it's a shirt
and a shirt because it's very stylish
shirt and hold on so take me a second
it's got this cute little raccoon a
little cut out and then a little cutout
on the shoulder oh cute how cute is that
that's very flattering get started today
at stitchfix.com whitney you'll get 25
percent off when you keep everything i'm
keeping everything in my fix on this one
stitchfix.com whitney for 25 percent off
when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
whitney i know you think that's cute but
it's not
that's my motto
stitch fix i know you think it's cute
but trust me it's not get stitch fix so
the advice you gave me that changed my
life or the best advice i ever got
after my dad died
very suddenly and
like gruesomely and
shittily um
i
was like i was in the like a numb state
where i was very ashamed of how i was
grieving because i was like shouldn't
you be crying more i was just like in
shock for a while i was very um
judgmental of how i was grieving you
know it's hard to understand it's like
hard to explain
and
as soon as you found out you called me
i did not pick up
power move had to make you sweat it out
alone yeah you called me
yeah and then i was just too s i didn't
know why like i was like just i wasn't
answering any calls you called me again
did not you just kept calling me and
finally
i picked up and i was like hey and you
were i remember this so vividly you said
hi
there's nothing i can do to help you
there's nothing i can say to make you
feel less pain
but the only thing i will suggest is
that for the next six months don't talk
to anyone who hasn't lost a parent
and i had those last two days such a big
part of why i wasn't able to grieve is
because people like what can i do can i
help you can i and you're like
now i'm trying to take care of their
feelings because they're uncomfortable
about my grieving and now i have to give
you a chore
and then i'm like oh yeah i guess you
could bring me dinner and then i'm
having to like
what do you want decide what a salad
like i'm having to make all these
decisions because someone else wants to
help but there's nothing they can do and
you just want there's nothing i can do
there's nothing anyone can do and use
and then from then on i talked to lizzie
kaplan kevin christie and only people
dead parents and it was such a fucking
game changer you said parties won't be
fun for a long time
you're gonna start hating you said a lot
of your close friends
will move further away
and a lot of people that are
acquaintances will become very close
friends and you're exactly right and you
said parties won't be fun
because people complain about their
parents so much you don't realize how
much people take for granted the fact
that they have parents like people at
parties was like oh my god my fucking
mom's texting me oh and you're like
that sounds awful
sounds really hard like just little
things like that
minus unavailable unavail yeah tech
unavailable tech on an ot
it's true i mean it's so funny listening
to this whitney because i'm like god i'm
i'm like taking in my own words um i'm
really interested in what i'm saying if
you took your own advice your life you
would be thriving so i i remember where
i was when i found out i remember where
i was when we connected i i was
in atlanta in a hotel room and paul told
me and
it is i do think it's important to
and here's the thing like so many people
don't know what to do with grief and
especially sudden loss like it's really
i have more sympathy now than i did when
i was 27 and lost my mom and came back
to la to do pilot season no i'm sorry
i'm sorry i believe you came this is
another thing that changed my life
there was a movie called year one with
jack black which was the movie to get it
was like at the time fewer movies were
getting made the way they are now like
now everyone just like
you know gets to make movies um at
different budget levels at the time it
was like there were three huge comedies
a year there were three roles to get and
if and you know
if judy greer wasn't available we had a
shot
right yeah blake bell and judy greer
were off doing something else
we had a chance i would just sit around
like hope joan cusack was pregnant or
hope
right that ida field was out of town
and so um
uh uh
everyone went out for this part
everybody wanted it i believe you went
in for maybe your first or second
audition with probably harold ramus yeah
after your mom had passed
and
at that point you don't really give a
fuck if you're gonna get it or not yes
and you get it yes and harold remus who
has since passed away i do believe and i
believed it then
um
he still remains on my team
like truly like that man remains um
[Music]
on my team i just i feel his presence
and he truly is one of those people i
know you've had these people in your
life too who changed the course or see
you
even if you're like not
savvy and know all the right things to
do they're like oh who cares about doing
it right like i see you have something
yes yes he was that person and this is
an audition auditions are never we're
going to rehearse it and make it like
and he also
i think i don't know there was just
something about the space he created for
me to be myself both in that audition
room and then on the set yeah that i
really appreciated but it you know grief
is
and harold
was a buddhist so i think
for him too
it was not uncomfortable to be around
grief you know buddhists really
accept suffering as a part of the human
condition
we need contrast yes and don't try to
run away from it don't try to pretend
it's not there it's welcomed in to the
experience you can't outrun it you can't
outrun it none of us are out running any
of this you know what i mean
and
the true comedic legends like that
understand that
the funniest people come from tragedy
city and that that's just a yes part of
the deal so i definitely had i felt like
my grief had a spot at the table
you know it it's very it's such a
strange thing or our culture denies it
we all deny it you know and like
we don't value age and the elderly like
we just pretend it's not happening so i
have now had more sympathy for the
people
when i came back to la after suddenly
losing my mom the people who didn't know
what to do with me
who i had to push out of my life i left
herald teams i was just like oh i can
never see that person again yeah yeah
yeah yeah like people were mine fields
when you're in that kind of pain things
get very black and white there's not a
lot of room for oh but she's probably
she's going through a bad breakup and so
there's not a lot of room for
compassion for other people's
limitations or dysfunctional behaviors
or ignorance or just blind spots because
it's just like there's no
something i didn't understand about
grief is that it's just so exhausting oh
yeah it's just like there's no energy
it's work there it's it's a full-time
job yes like crying sleeping hydrating
so that you can cry more like dealing
with the uh the storage unit that
there's stuff in from the deceased and
now i have to go to florida to the
storage unit again like it's just the
family everybody being at their
worst because of grief and like it just
is a it's a full-time job i mean it took
me like a year
sure and i think the other like the the
myth around it is that it's linear that
that you
it will constantly get easier
it's just not true i think in some ways
the shock wears off yes i don't believe
i'm going to see my parents again but
then you have a
big moment in your life and you're like
i just the one person i want to call i
can't call of course yeah i've had a
really hard time recently with people
post-pandemic reuniting with their
parents yeah you know where there's been
something for me where
i start to almost feel like i'm going to
get to see them too
and then i'm like reminded that i won't
um
my father
who passed away in 2016 but before he
died it was he was sort of this the kind
of the
the gatekeeper of a lot of memories with
my mom and an unlikely one and not a
reliable narrator and and my sisters and
i would get so upset because like there
were questions we wanted answered yeah
he was like i can't remember oh
i can't remember you know just simply
couldn't remember anything um it was
also tricky because you don't live
assuming you're going to lose someone
soon so you don't lock things in you
take it all for granted totally but he
arrives in la
and he presents a journal to me
what is it with your family insurance
[Applause]
no
my dad was a union steam fitter grew up
in the bronx you know
a big thick bronx accent tough guy
and he
turns to me and goes you know i can
never really tell you how i feel about
you
and your mom just knew what to say she
knew what to say
and i found this
and she wrote something in here for you
and uh
it's just
so beautiful
and i wanted you to have
now i'm like
like a letter from my mom like what is
she and i go thanks chad and he hands me
a journal now it looks familiar
it is scientology pamphlet i open it up
it's a line journal but on the front
there is a lovely note
about how much i mean to this person
what they see in me
and i said dad this is from my friend
nancy carowana
who you all so dated
and conflated this is
not this is the back of my it says stay
cool over see you in the fall and i knew
because it was a yearbook it was a it
was a 7th grade birthday gift
and the writing was so beautifully a
simple but also like written from a
seventh grader
and there's the heart she's spelled cool
with that hey
do you think
this isn't mommy's handwriting
you know what a message half the words
are spelled incorrectly that
was just so confusing as someone that
now is at a point where my coping
mechanism with sadness is actually just
crying yeah which is
what it should have always been but we
know it's push it down make jokes be
silly be irreverent whatever
eat
hi
drink what i i now when i'm and that is
what i define happiness as is when
you're uh things are good you're happy
when things are bad you're sad it's not
about when things are going bad you're
happy that's insanity that's not
happiness right it's just being able to
have the appropriate reaction to
something if something's sad you should
cry uh whereas i used to be if something
was sad i'd be like everything's fine
i'm just gonna make a bunch of like
corny jokes and just like talk louder
right um and uh
so yeah i get that when you see people
at weddings making about themselves
complaining getting drunk i'm just like
yep oh like this is triggered like
someone's happiness is just my dad spent
the weekend going to garage sales and
yard sales in santa barbara looking for
a tripod
you know and we'll never quite get to
the bottom of why that was what he took
on as his fantastic distraction
or
um we'll never know you know why that
was he was obsessed with let me tell you
something
he told you he was looking for a tripod
he drove around the block and cried in
his car for six hours straight i mean or
something or that's what he needed to do
some kind of like uh distraction or a
way to lose yourself in a task
it's impossible because he could have
just gone to best buy and gotten one
sure so to go to yard sales you know
you're not finding one there right but
my dad's mentality was also like this is
a tripod i'm not flying back with the
tripod so i'm not buying a new tripod so
i am on a hunt it's a specific task yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know what i mean like
it's a specific people that don't have
tripods probably
situation will be like i'm going to go
to a bunch of yard sales to try to get a
ring light
they don't have they're not there
they're not at the point where they're
not in the inventory they're not vintage
yeah
they're not in a place yet where someone
doesn't need them anymore
no
as you get older you don't need a tripod
less right exactly it's not something
like that you had a good run yeah you're
holding on to that no you know and
there's not so much wear and tear
but they're also i don't want the tripod
you gave up there's something
deeply real yeah
because their job is to i think stay
still the legs is janky and you know it
and it's your wedding yeah
so those photos are just oh my god
whitney so anyway
all of that is to say right that grief
is not grief shows up in a variety of
different ways for all of us and on the
topic of men that aren't able to really
adequately deal with their emotions or
don't know how or weren't taught or etc
we're taught to man up and don't be a
pussy etc etc and crying as a bitch it's
gay all that shit um i was dating a guy
from texas and we went on a trip where i
had my big the way that i used to get
men in my day was uh that i had all the
screeners all the oscars screeners
so you had this sweet sweet
i know i'm older than the girls you date
and a little crazy but
i've got fences so
a month before anyone can get it at
blockbuster
i've got the dvd of the
changeling rush over
so i he i i brought the the the
your goods look at your wares
i opened my suitcase and just screamed
the abundance of screeners and at this
point it was like see i mean i had house
of cards like every scene like it was
like now tv's up for awards okay
and came in the same time platforms got
them all got them all
so he chooses fences
which by the way i had already seen on
christmas day
and because viola we stan and um i
pretended i hadn't seen it
of course but yeah let's watch that so
codependent and
within the first 10 minutes he's sobbing
so uncontrollably oh my
that i
i was like oh this is this is what it
has to come to for you guys
like you store it up
and on a mexico vacation you're you're
right
convulsing with sadness right over a
pretend thing yep
yeah because it has it hasn't had any
yeah how lucky you're the real therapist
is viola dave i would love yeah to be
able to only emotionally connect but you
got that for free a month earlier it
took denzel and viola to get you to
process that you were molested oh my god
it must be nice so funny to never feel
anything
until denzel
calls action yep and says you should
yeah by the way also if you were dating
someone that got screeners what was your
plan for this
grief truly
truly how are you going to process it
you can do this at the grove
people around you you have to do this in
a penthouse with me oh my god and of
course it's interesting because for a
long time i actually stayed away from
like even now to be quite honest i don't
love consuming
things that make me feel sad
i'm good hard pass and then the one that
just came out i wanted to see it because
i know the performances will be amazing
but there's the movie pieces of a woman
i don't like that title already i don't
know what it's a party i want her whole
i was like a whole woman coming this
fall whole night not interested in her
pieces about her baby that died on the
and i just i'm like i'm good i just
don't want to live in this i can do that
all by myself like i'm
really okay yeah it's so wild to me i
also um we do need to get back to
something i forgot to say
that i don't remember oh why why you
inspired me to get uh write and create
my own stuff i i really reject this
a bunch of bulletproofs describing
your acting choices
because i believe i believe you are to
me
make the funniest choices wait that
means
and i hate everything
you are it's and you don't have to but
um uh you are consistently the most
surprising comedy performer the mo
the only person that i've been as
surprised about their choices was when i
did a pilot uh called the station that i
didn't i don't know what happened i got
cast because i was taller than you by
the way one of the funniest stories i've
ever heard is i believe it was that
pilot where you had the eye
wasn't your eye twitching uncontrollable
[Applause]
then why don't we tell the story about
how you used to tweak your braces with a
fork well i don't have money to pay for
the job sure the insurance doesn't cover
you after 27. i remember seeing you at
an audition like with a knife like
adjusting your brain my own work but i
had to do my own there was no way that
was doing anything behind there was no
way you were done that's what the
problem was is lots of times they would
pop off
and so then maybe because you were um
jamming a knife for sure but i was so
behind on my payments right dr mario paz
right that i could no longer go back i
mean they told me at the front desk like
you can't come here until you pay and i
said but i have a set of
braces behind my teeth i've had to
re-learn how to talk
okay
with these steps
you've given me i can't book any of
these jobs to get money to pay for this
because i
so i had to when things would pop off i
had to fix them myself and
take a you know plier and adjust wires
it wasn't great
these were tough times these were tough
times
so you changed my life uh because so
june and i when we were like hitting the
audition circuit before we were offer
only
before we were
uh offer contingent on media
not completely bombing the meeting which
i'm like i'm never gonna get this if
it's me if it's meaning there's no way
never never just can i plea i always say
can i please audition i would prefer to
i would prefer to audition then have it
be a personality yes because what are
you looking for i don't know
so now i just have to be the character
and i don't understand no idea no and
like actually if you want to see my
personality like i'm going to show you
something that's so strange yeah yeah
yeah you know what i mean like if you
just want to see him a normal person to
work with what you're actually going to
see is like me doing a version of myself
that's so wildly uncomfortable we're on
a date it's really do you want to go on
a date what are those meetings for like
see the body of my work if you think i
can do it i can if i can't i can't i
can't i can't
well you're just asking me on a date and
honestly hire me because i deserve it
and then we'll decide if we'll go on a
date after we ride that's right we'll
just let's just do it the old fashioned
way that's right
and um
yeah to me i always feel like that's a i
just need to see if she looks like her
picture oh i need to see how she looks
now
oh whitney i hadn't considered that
that's what it is it's sort of sometimes
i feel about the industry like i feel
about men like the less i know okay so
this is the way that you change my life
um i love when people inspire you and
they don't even know they were doing it
as my favorite thing so
i went into this audition so again there
used to be three movies a year everyone
would go out for and all your friends
turned into your enemy that week
strange yes yes we'd run the auditions
together i'd be like do it this way
that's hilarious sabotaging each other
seeing each other i mean my favorite is
the it took me so long to learn that
when you're in an audition waiting room
when people start conversations with you
so that you can't focus like you know
what you look like i don't know and then
i'm like it took me so long to realize i
was being sabotaged it was this it was a
character that was a pregnant sister
that drank you definitely booked this
job so so correct any of my math no yeah
sounding familiar yeah but
um
well first of all you're the only person
i know
that
has more
hair products and
like
like electric hair devices in your purse
than i do
also i'm not afraid to travel with my
equipment also also
mary poppins also you will look in her
purse
and
this is something i admire about you so
much the
pink
sponge makeup sponge is loose i know
people are going to have trouble with it
it's not in a zip lock it's not gotten
better with it mainly because you you
really got me i know i remember when you
saw that you were very disturbed okay
not i mean i'm not like i don't want to
be cheese it crumbs i don't want to be a
conspiracy theorist but there has been
talk about covet originating in your
purse
yes patient zero
there was definitely bat blood on there
i mean there was so many things it's
supposed to be pink it was a charcoal
grain
and i was just like finding the areas
that were still like okay to use
and so
i walk in and you're you're
june
commits in a way to everything she does
that i've always watched and inspired
there is a i am going for this in a way
and maybe this is how you've always been
but also having sisters whatever birth
order
january 4th
heidi rose robbins will tell me why but
it maybe after your mom died you were
just in a different gear
but
i walked into an audition
where the character was supposed to be
pregnant and
you
were
lifting your uh
probably
you know
hot topic mini skirt and you were
jamming like a pregnant belly yep into
your dress and and i think you even
asked someone to like can you click i
mean it was like you were in your
underwear it was like i was always in
process in the waiting room too it
wasn't no it was a sight it was like
watching a homeless person start their
day
i mean it was like she's like she would
like put a mirror on the cat and be
doing it this is my space this is my
heart
teasing she's pulling hair clip like
she's putting extensions in she's asking
people to hold things can you just
put it together you're doing it takes a
village so she's putting a
pregnant belly in
and i'm looking at you
and i was like and i had to go after you
and you go in and you can hear laughs
through the fucking thing
and i'm like
i'm just i'm not a good audition like
i'm never gonna be able to do this i'm
never
gonna be brave enough i'm never gonna be
um
uh uh give no fucks
as i'm never gonna be as free as that
i'm i wouldn't even know where to get a
pregnant belly like i'm sure it was a
pillow from my bag
but like that was the thing it's like i
was making choices but on a budget yeah
yeah i was trying to just spend money
yeah yeah yeah i mean it was a trash bag
you found uh on your way yeah yeah it
was it was two wigs sewn together well
that's because by the way so casey and i
both came up from the stella adler
studio of acting where
the whole this is so boring but at nyu
you had these different studios and
there were different kind of technique
acting techniques that you might and
like meisner you would say you're
wearing a pink shirt i'm wearing a pink
shirt you're wearing a pink shirt i'm
wearing like to listen listen listen
repetition
experimental theater wing
uh had its own thing
the acting studio i went to in l.a was
called beverly hills playhouse and it
took me six months to realize it was a
scientology feeding ground most of them
are in hell and every single note was uh
trying to convince me that i was
molested
um
so that i would go to the church of
scientology and yes you guys hold those
things if i get if this if this studio
gets me to a point to where i can afford
scientology i'll do i'm in how about
that so
in the stella adler studio of acting our
whole thing
was create the space so if you're doing
like three sisters you're bringing in a
couch
yes you are if you're doing the same
role you better bring in a live bird
shit you're bringing your costumes
so that was like you always knew a
stella other student because we were
lugging around like
literally like desks from our dorm room
carrot top went to the stella
theater that was his training but i find
it so interesting that you say like oh i
couldn't be that brave because you i see
you as one of the bravest people i know
that's so weird absolutely like the best
and now it's your turn to say however
i will i'm happy to i absolutely will
because i do see you that way as just so
courageous
whitney
absolutely and speaking of that time and
i know we're talking about like
auditions and sizing each other up but
you
were one of the first women i met
who was i knew was in my circle of like
parts i was going out for
who i f you had the right
lens on the industry um you did and i
know like
your waiting room banter you were
connecting all of us yeah and saying
like this is not real life
bitches i was always like this is this
isn't it what's going on in there ain't
it
like we are out here and so let's all
connect i want to be like we're
underpaid i know how much the budget is
yeah they're paying us a thousand
dollars when they have a 20 million
dollar budget so just so willing to
like make fun and contextualize what
this all what i was going on
just to see i'm like i know i'm not
gonna get this i mean i i i would
audition
at a time where when you're sitting in
the waiting room
they would
be closing deals on the actress who was
booking yeah
and she's in she said yes to the tiffany
role and you're standing there you've
spent three days on the tiffany side so
i was like i'm gonna go fucking in there
and i'm gonna learn how this works
so i went in auditioning them i would
just be like who's the director what's
your name oh cool so how should this go
like how why was this a period and not a
comma like i would just i was like
probably too annoying to hire but i was
like i need to figure out and then i
would meet casting directors and i'd be
like i'm gonna hire you one day you're
nice to actors or like you you
read the copy
in a way that isn't just running through
it so the actor can't you know what i'm
saying you're acting like there's
certain casting directors who would have
people actually act with you right and
um so i just was like i'm never gonna
get this job but i have to get something
out of this it can't be a waste of time
so i'm either okay i'm gonna hire that
casting director one day or like i'm
never gonna do that
when i have power like okay that's what
you did so then when i then went on to
work on on your show and of course what
we were told by the head of nbc that we
looked too much alike for me to be cast
i tried to
uh cast june to play my sister as soon
as i got a television show oh no my my
best friend
because i wanted you to be my real best
friend um and i
like literally was like straight off for
june is the person to play my best
friend in the show and they were like oh
they look too much alike that was i
remember where i was when i got that
phone call
it was so imaginative qualified the best
person for the job and what's so funny
is i talk about commitment i actually
had that thought i was like we both are
brunettes the same height and have high
cheekbones like this is gonna they they
don't have the capacity no one had the
ability to just go hey can you dye your
hair put some highlights in put some
lowlights and this is and then when zoe
lister jones came in and auditioned i
was like we're both pale we're both
brunette i sent her to a salon in new
york
to bleach her hair for the audition she
didn't have the job
and diet red
she started going bald oh my god
oh my god and i was like clip it back in
we'll deal with this later and she had
to go red and they were like great and i
was like it was about hair color no of
course it was because here's the thing
like but they never would do that to men
like they would never say have you seen
scrubs
everywhere looks exactly the same you
can't tell one from the other but with
women it's like number four kings
they diversity for men is short and tall
absolutely but for women it's like oh no
no no please tell me who i want to fuck
and then who i want to be my mom okay
because i have to know who's
who's the eight yes who's the sidekick
eight and i know she's funny just
because she
um but what i was gonna say though is
that
you
and that whole process even and here's
the thing about not getting the part
because i was devastated to not get that
part but i was devastated the show went
we now have to pause this incredibly
engaging
likely pulitzer prize-winning interview
to talk to you about
a little thing
i just i want to have a little mini
heart to heart with you because i think
we all know
the things that are taboo subjects those
things that we all agree we can't talk
about at family dinners or funerals the
dmv with the guys who wear flip-flops in
december you know who you are
but one of my forbidden favorites is
shock to everyone
it's sex come on come on
let's get it out there sex sex sex talk
talk talk take care
we shouldn't be uncomfortable talking
about alisexa
or our lack of the desire for it that
happens too the loss of desire could be
something called
hsdd which stands for hypoactive sexual
desire disorder hsdd is the most common
form of sexual dysfunction in
premenopausal women many women don't
know the name but they know the feeling
all too well we're talking about being
frustrated that you're rarely if ever
wanting to have sex and this might be a
very hot take but living with a
distressingly low libido it can be very
annoying okay it's a crapola fest is
what it is
but if it sounds familiar you're not
alone and you have a lot of options
listen up friends meet addie or flip
answering the fda approved little pink
pill for certain pre-menopausal women
frustrated by their own low sex drive
are you ready to learn more yes you are
pull out your little pocket computer
head to
a-d-d-y-i dot-com and schedule an online
visit today use the code good for you at
checkout to find out if addy could be
good for you for only ten dollars
that's good for you at a d d y i
dot com addi is for premenopausal women
with acquired generalized hypoactive or
low sexual desire disorder hsdd who have
not had problems with low sexual desire
in the past and who have low sexual
desire no matter the type of sexual
activity the situation or the sexual
partner the low sexual desire is
traveling to them and is not due to a
medical or mental health problem
problems in a relationship or medicine
or any other drug use addy is not for
use in men or to enhance sexual
performance your risk of severe low
blood pressure and fainting is increased
if you drink one to two standard
alcoholic drinks close to your addy dose
so wait at least two hours after
drinking before taking addie at bedtime
your risk of severe low blood pressure
and fainting is also increased if you
take a certain prescription over the
counter or herbal medications or have
liver problems low blood pressure and
fainting can happen when you take addi
even if you don't drink alcohol or take
other medicines sleepiness sometimes
serious can occur common side effects
include dizziness nausea tiredness
difficulty falling asleep or staying
asleep and dry mouth see full pi
including boxed warning at addy dot com
slash pi or call 844
pink
pill that's eight four four p i n k p i
learn about the little pink pill addie
addie dot com a-d-d-y-i
dot com
i love ritual this is no secret to
anyone ritual vitamins i take on a daily
basis i'm legally not allowed to tell
you all the things i believe that it has
done for me
amazingly so i'm going to shut up and
just stick to prompter because i love
this product so much that i go on
tangents and then i'm i i get in i get a
little tis tisk so i love ritual because
it's an amazing foundation for health
it's great taste super flexible
subscription service the ease of
incorporating emily you really put this
into my voice uh ease of incorporating
into daily rituals what tense is this
you you know that they give us copy for
us to read it right this is like latin
well
it's theirs okay it's their copy but
hold on okay
that's exactly what they wanted which is
why i love it so much i thought that's
what you were gonna say
which is finally i'm seeing words
spelled correctly and correct grammar i
got confused
and now we've got their protein powder
where all you do is add water shake
and sip
i love rituals so much i bet i can take
down this whole shake i made in the time
it takes you to read more copy
that seems unnecessary
oh she's going okay okay okay is that
how you suck a dick you're like let's go
hurry you rush them along okay just
ahead of it
uh ritual is made traceable you deserve
to know what you're putting in your body
and why and emily puts so few things in
her body around both holes that you
really she's gotta she's probably gonna
be careful with what she does with this
one-of-a-kind visible supply chain you
always know what's in your formula
there's no regular roll there's no red
number five sorry emily
is drinking this and where
they tell you where the ingredients come
from
and then they're included okay i'm just
gonna read slower because this is just
funny ritual supporters daily health for
tomorrow as much as what happens if you
just keep drinking it are you oh my god
you could
puke um made with nutrients to support
bones brains which emily's going to need
her brain supported now because she says
no oxygen in it for
i have not asked her to do this i want
this to be very clear that this show's
turned into fear factor and it was not
my idea and muscles to help maintain
muscle mass as you age not that anyone
here is aging uh so why not just shake
up your ritual to make trying okay stop
okay to make trying something new less
scary which emily sucking a dick is new
and scary ritual offers
there's a lot of drink in this cup huh
michael's so close by the way the reason
i don't want to stop you from drinking
this is this is the only healthy thing
i've ever seen you put in your body so
i'm trying to get you to really uh just
deep throat as much ritual as you
possibly can
i'm so close not
that i can't take available now
you didn't you can't tell that based on
how long she sucked on that phallic
thing no i was like that is a delta
bitch right there
um
ritual offers a you're dizzy emily's
truly dizzy
ritual offers a money-back guarantee if
you're not 100 in love plus my listeners
get 10 off during your first three
months and if you're my listener i love
you i want you to be healthy i want you
to take care of yourself ritual makes it
so easy please please please go to
ritual.com what need to add essential
protein today that is ritual.com
whitney
here's what i'm gonna say is like you
you never got enough credit for your
performance in that show because i
thought you did a fucking amazing job
but but i will also you know that they
animated my face without telling me so
any of my acting choices and facial
expressions were fixed and posted i
didn't know about it
i was an animated cartoon in the show
this was the first like hybrid live
action i
am a smurf yes i am jessica rabbit on
the show so i'm like trying to make all
these like complicated like really
specific choices and they went in and
like took out all my eye bags and lines
on my face so i just looked
like i was not making any choices i
cannot believe that
well i thought your performance although
maybe it was
animated
that's great
the pixels did a great job i thought
they all did great i think that guy who
changed who had the mouse and changed
all of your expressions painted over
every frame i mean both of you
collaborating honestly it's he was the
larry david to my jerry's here's what i
will say because most
here's the thing about like the industry
and entertainment and art and whatever
it's like you're gonna fail you're not
gonna get the thing more than you're
gonna get it right and so i really do
believe like those it's so important to
know how to fail and to not get it it's
so important and you
when i didn't get it i remember how you
called me and i remember what you said
to me and i remember
how you took care of me in that process
and that was so important because i i
thought really that was it for me i was
like if i can't get this
with i know i have chemistry with this
person
i know that audition went well like i
know this is all right if this doesn't
work then i don't know what i got and
like people don't want me if i can't get
this what can i get you know and
you took me through that process
from audition to auditioning again
to then calling to say i told you to
lose some weight yeah
you were giving me some pretty harsh
feedback copious notes and emails
but
that's
real it was the first time i was like oh
wow
she handled this gracefully
and she took care of me through the
whole thing and then i would go on to
guest on the show and play
a character and i had so much fun and
you also took care of me on set and took
care of all the actors on set
you really did so all of like the
processing of your own experience as we
all have like you really do know how to
talk to actors i mean i can see it in
your movie too like you know how
we need to be taken care of that's what
i think people don't always know about
you you're such a natural caretaker
yeah it's called uh you know you're
gonna say it's quite i'm in a program oh
you're gonna be 14 years old
uh and coda but yes no i i i it's a
beautiful quality and i
thank you and i think that you know and
i i know i self-deprecate a lot and like
i have this thing where if you give
yourself a compliment you're like a
malignant narcissist and taking away
someone else's shine that's old that's
old but i do know my strengths and
weaknesses ice is not one of them but
i
for a couple
having been in so many
emotionally dangerous vicious situations
as an actor
and watching my performance suffer and
and to me it's like to me acting is like
you're always on a porn set
everyone's that naked everyone's that
emotional everyone's that scared
and i know how scared actors are and i
know how infantilized they are and i
know how
if fear is present no other emotion can
exist through it they just can't so it's
like not only is that my natural
proclivity and i enjoy it
because i had to be a caretaker for
others at a very young age and myself i
like it it's not like doing anyone a
favor it's not a conscious effort it's
you guys are my family i go into a set
and it's my family you're my sister
you're my brother you know and
then you also get the best work out of
people that's true and then if someone
else is is great at what they're doing
you get better
the better the other actors are the
better you get and then you all get to
go home with pride and grace and and um
it's all it makes it all worth it
totally but no and i don't know that i
would have known that i mean you talk
about me calling you and your dad died
and being with you in grief like i don't
know at that age that i would have known
make the direct phone call sit with
someone let them feel what they're
feeling well i had been told after
giving weeks of my life to auditioning
for a part and losing it because i was
too tall or too shrill or not pretty
enough or to this or do that and then i
can email it's like ah it's not going
it's it's not going to go your way
forward it's not moving forward
and then going to a test
which a test meant you not only
could get a job that could change your
life and get rid of your debt and get
you into an apartment without
cockroaches and health insurance
that at that point the stakes it's not
just about like not getting it or i
don't get to be famous or i don't get to
be on this tv show it's like i was
counting on that to be able to get
health insurance like i won't be able to
get my braces tightened if i don't get
this job so so at that level the stakes
are so high it's not like i want to be
famous it's almost like i want to
survive if that's okay i would like to
get a pap smear for
the first time i do find actors to be
the
for the most part like the most
intelligent also yes
in terms of just like cutting through
the bullshit seeing everything we're
with the crew we're picking up people's
moods we're like little honestly like
dogs are little balls of energy people
who are who are constantly figuring out
where do i fit in how am i a part of
this you know the dogs are how i pick
the guys at it
whoa so
if my dog doesn't like a guy
he's gone wow they know because they
know i'll talk myself into it he has a
good job he's a really nice person he
lives here
like you know he's been married before
that's good he knows how commitment
works and how marriage is gonna be hard
whatever if my dog's not interested i'm
like okay you just saved me two years
see it's so interesting because i feel
like when i first met you you were not
the animal person you are today
that's been a really long journey well
it's weird because i was always an
animal person but i was you did poor so
yes okay and didn't believe i deserved
any kind of unconditional love so i used
to rescue dogs for other people and get
other people dogs and raise money for
dogs and dinner but you didn't have your
own dogs and my therapist was like why
don't you have a dog and i was like well
because like
i'm busy and i travel a lot and she's
like okay then you'll just get a house
sitter or send it to like i didn't
believe i deserved
that kind of joy emily you were with me
when i first got it no it was eliza when
i first got a dog like i just didn't
believe that was for me that was for
like happy people
wow yeah
and then
i also was like i can't get a dog it's
gonna die one day
why would i set myself up for that
but yes now i'm like i know
that number one dogs don't need to be
outside running around all the time
they actually sleep most of the day
if you go out of town for two days
you're not abandoning it so coming from
a childhood where i was abandoned a lot
i was like left a lot and like was very
scared of the mercurial inconsistent
attention i was
i was projecting on to the dog that like
oh i get this if i leave for two days
it's gonna be heartbroken
it's fine it is fine i mean i think you
know some parents get upset when people
like
compare their relationship with their
pets kids and i'm like no i i get that i
get that it is such a similar
connection in terms of i am
i am loving you so much
and preparing you to leave me
yeah
and that's a fucked up like mental
sort of journey the goal is for you to
leave me that's how my therapist does
and why i stay with her she's like the
goal is not for you
if i'm doing my job well you do not come
back forever yes and you are comfortable
with our separation
and you are comfortable and confident
without me that's what we're heading
towards that's what we want here so
um there's this amazing uh meditation
t-shirt that i did a 10-month course on
attachment strategies and changing your
attachment style um i went in person for
the first month then did the vimeo
version um full disclosure but i've
never taken a meditation i get bored i
get antsy i get
sadness comes up i don't like it i'm
uncomfortable i like start doing like
isometric exercises and kegels like i i
feel like i'm not productive enough i
just
i'm not there yet and meditation is just
not a match for me great but
when i went to george haas's class uh he
would give you specific meditations uh
forgiveness meditations that you would
say over and over again that have
changed my life which is like i forgive
you you forgive me i forgive myself so
use that's the meditation you say i
forget so when someone acts shitty i
just go i forgive you you forgive me i
fear myself or when i do something i'm
not proud i forgive myself like it's
it's a refrain that just kind of by this
pavlovian reaction to come up but one of
the big ones is how to be in a
relationship that is interdependent not
codependent so uh uh my therapist always
says if trains are uh going
basically next to each other they can go
forever but if the rails cross they
crash right so the idea is always to be
here and not here so whenever i'm in a
situation where i'm like meddling in my
boyfriend's thing or taking on his
consequences or trying to solve a
problem that's not my problem i
literally visually have to hold my hands
up like this and just go okay you're
doing that you stay here or
the other visual that i need because i
need like a tangible example to
understand something
um
if you hold
sand in your hand like this you can hold
it forever but if you hold it like this
you lose it so the idea is always to
hold here
and then that helped me be able to wrap
my head around
when george haas said
the the motto of the uh meditation
class is i love you keep going
wow not i love you stay let me smother
you so you can't grow so yeah it was
just like news flash it was like
breaking news the idea of like i love
you keep going keep growing and we'll
move forward together
you're not
attached to me you're not my skin tag
that's the only way that this won't
breed resentment
the idea is for you to be able to exist
without me
because then in 10 years if you don't i
hate you
it's so true and it's also like with
children i love them so much i mean i
would have 10 more if paul allowed me to
i'd have all the children in the world i
would absolutely love love love do you
have like a we have to i think we're
done okay yes but
not
i i would have more
i would have i i would have all the kids
you know like you'd have all the dogs
i'm sure i'd have all the kids and i'd
also have all the dogs yeah but i just
love them and
it's hard to to reconcile that kind of
like separate but close and preparing
this thing that you love so much to
leave you yeah and to know the goal it's
just so and what
love in this moment is not solving your
problem for you it's watching you suffer
a little bit or stub your toe or put
your hand in the fire so that you learn
the hard way because if i protect you
from consequences you're gonna go out in
the world and get your ass kicked it's
also like how do you look at behavior
that is bringing up like sometimes
behavior their behavior brings something
up in me and i'm like but that's not me
doing that because you're worried you
pass something on or just like that's a
reflection so the ego comes in and it's
like oh what are people seeing do they
think i'm not doing this right all of
the questions and
really being willing as a parent to be
like that's happening this is the moment
we're in
people are witnessing
and you are a child and i your behavior
is not me
i'm over here
you know and it's not that there aren't
consequences to your behavior there are
right right right you know and it's not
that there's not gonna be discipline you
are all my dna but yeah
that was yours that was your choice like
i'm not having a tantrum on the ground i
think that's really hard
two days a month as soon as a month i am
but i'm ovulating right now i do get
kind of cranky ovulating too maybe it is
me you know like but truly it's it's
such a
it's such a there are these little
teachers who are like oh it's really
it has forced me
to
learn how to like love something
so closely and also
detach yeah from the experience too
and still be close it's like this
it is this and you cannot take on their
consequences or take responsibility
because then they will learn
to do that
yes and i do think you know i i
i do think i mean i never heard my
parents apologize to me once not one
single time but i also think it's
important for them to see i mean come
now i can't imagine being a child and
having seeing my parents like offer that
because it is an offering of like hey
you can make a mistake and and you can
recover here's what i'll say back then
good parenting was your kids are
alive
period period so they're full stop there
is a uh
sketchy um
uh it's not rehab it's like a wellness
weekend called the landmark forum and i
know what you know about you know well
you know well i've been in this city
you've you've yeah you've had to manage
sure sure it's scientology light
basically um but you get it for a
weekend and i've tons of friends that
have gone it never really try i always
i'm like 12-step program emdr like these
are just the things that work for me if
you can go to an expensive place for a
weekend and totally be fixed
congratulations i'm i'm not there
my amygdala is just not wired
that way um but
one of the things they say because i
ended up talking to someone and when
someone's like landmark form because
they always trying to get you to go and
do the whole thing it's like a cult and
i was like god this fucking thing and
then i was like oh wait a second i don't
know what they do there and i'm just
dismissing it because it just seems
superficial and
and like a scam but like and i asked
someone that i didn't want to talk to at
all because the most annoying people i
know have have gone to and i don't think
that's a coincidence but um i finally
said what about this place
was so powerful to you because i was
being self-righteous i was being sort of
um
uh kind of just snobbish about like
my damage they could never handle my
damage and the way i do my therapy is
superior i was like oh that's gross i'm
being judgy how was it what was it yeah
that made you go this is it
and something they do in the beginning
is they say the first thing they say is
how many of you here
believe your parents didn't do a good
enough job with you
everybody raises their hand
and then the guy goes
what if i told you their only job was to
keep you alive how'd they do
and it's sort of this forgiveness
exercise of oh given the tools they had
they kind of nailed it my dad's dad
never said i love you he was traumatized
war veteran that was like
you know like i love love you what are
you talking about i just picked you up
from school i could have made you walk
home barefoot six miles like that was
amazing parenting back then you're
welcome yeah like what oh i didn't hang
out with you enough sorry i was in a
coal mine i'm sorry i didn't have time
to play with you in the sandbox
like what are you know so i think
there's
just to go to that radical forgiveness
place because it's you know yeah they
didn't have oprah it's true it's true i
mean listen i do feel i do feel it is an
enormous responsibility to be the
steward of someone's childhood and i
don't take that lightly and i i
i consider that
a privilege and also a giant
responsibility and i do think that if
people are thinking of having kids and
not ready to take on that emotional
responsibility they should not i know i
have to let you go i mean my period cup
is almost full
my period cup runs overflowing i truly
will you inspire me to both care more
and to care less interesting you will be
in uh forced to come back
if you don't i will accuse you of that i
will ask a toxic misogynist to talk
about ass backwards because i would like
to do a entire episode on the movie you
and casey made called ass backwards um
i would like to just by the way i will
never forget the first time we screened
that movie you were in the audience it
was at like uta's old screening room
and
we didn't sit down casey and i didn't
sit down to watch i was so terrified we
stood in the back and i just listened to
your laugh
i'm sorry i ruined that no you didn't
because i was like oh my god it's okay
because you know the feeling of
screening something and all you're
listening to is the laughs and
we just heard yours above everybody
else's obvious look
i was the real i couldn't be a star of
the movie but i was the star of the
stream but and there were places you
were laughing where no one else was
laughing but casey and i thought was
those are spots that we thought were so
funny and i was like okay like
everything that was landing the smart
people get it was the most important it
truly was it truly was i also believe
that was my first producer credit on a
movie
i believe i believe i am a producer
you're an executive producer this is the
first gofundme i have ever thought was
worth it honestly like the first
gofundme ever like people had no idea it
was a kickstarter campaign yeah but at
the time we raised fifty thousand
dollars to finish the movie i mean we do
need to come back and i both need to
come back there's a lot to discuss okay
can i just write how i describe your
comedic choices as a performer
i spent so much time doing this the fact
that i wrote this down is so dorky but
i'm so obsessed with you as a performer
your ethos is that of someone who feels
every conversation they're having is
wildly beneath them
but has decided to engage solely as an
act of charity and to be a good role
model
i do feel like listen i'm i'm a leo moon
and that energy is like the benevolent
queen like i'm happy to spend time with
the you know the good people because i
want to set a good example i don't
i shouldn't be here but that's just what
the stars say but how else are they
going to learn yeah how else would they
learn you know
it's good to touch down with real people
right every now and then every now and
then it makes it feel relatable sure
does it's important for me to see yeah
and then uh
you're uh oh on the tinge of i'm doing
you a favor by even engaging in this
conversation
because a lot of times when you make
community choices talking to the person
is like the third or fourth thing you're
doing right like you're doing you've got
other there's other
you're doing it while and every now and
then you forget you're even talking to
the person
um
uh
oh my god that's a haughty
above it all energy yet completely
beneath it at the same time yeah yeah
yeah this is all feeling quite right um
you have an all-knowing bewilderment
you know everything and nothing at the
same time you know everything yet
nothing at once i'm trying to think what
because these are all based on different
characters you played but there's the
there's always this thing where like i
don't know if she knows everything or
nothing
because she's searching for her
knowledge i can't tell if she's
searching
for how to say it yeah i feel like this
is like this is very julie gristle white
from burning love one of my favorite i
hate when people talk about their
characters but it does as you're saying
that i'm like oh i think you just sort
of put language to yes yes
if i was a director and how to direct
that character this is maybe what i
would say you have an unflappable nature
where you land each word where you're
clearly clearly hearing the person
but not really listening
also
also i've said this about exactly one
person and it's you your active
listening is usually funnier than most
people's acting
i remember
when you were on the show we uh that i
did we were in post going like
should we just be on june for my line
like your
cover your coverage of you listening was
funnier than anything else so we're like
let's just let's just do a single on
june i guess for this whole scene and
we're just voice over actors in the
background well we're animated anyway so
who cares i guess because it makes you
as most people what they'll act and then
when it's not their line they just stop
acting to think of their next one yeah
no that's my honestly my favorite thing
to do is listen as an actor like i
actually prefer i this sounds so
accurate i hate it but like when there's
fewer lines because
you get to listen
your listening is very it's just so like
like you'll just take things in in a way
that is so much funnier than what
anyone's doing verbally i will never
forget whitney when you
we were doing like
you very kindly agreed to do an event
that pawn i asked you to do and you were
hilarious and emceed a charity event
called voice for the animals my
nightmare but you just nailed it
effortlessly but why ace uh mc mc let's
say hosted i'm so sorry
i don't know why i said that it's like
that makes me go like keep it going like
mc is basically like like a man
i'm so sorry it is a live studio
audience understand
thank you for that person yeah
distinctions so
we were backstage before we went on and
you had already done your hair and
makeup and i was getting like final
touches uh-huh i feel like i've melted
off i i this is is this totally i it is
a salvador dali we have the same face so
if we are doing
imperfect women are in so he doesn't
have a job anymore
so you had already you were ready to go
like you had already done your last
looks you were just going over your
script and this makeup artist came over
it was a long script i just remember
getting there yeah i should have it
comedy hero got it major apologies and
then we spent a lot of time taking
pictures with lisa vanderpump's
pomeranians
i never want to go back to that moment
in my mind and that i had to look over
and see you do that apologies again for
sending that email
or did paul i feel like paul maybe was
the one who did the act here's what i'll
say
our our dear friend casey wilson has
forever changed uh my ability to see and
ask is inappropriate
after and we've discussed it on this
podcast uh she asked
before her wedding if me and a couple of
her other single girlfriends would do a
flash mob at her wedding to single
ladies just so you know i learned this
four weekends of rehearsal i learned
this information from this here podcast
never
shared that i actually was like oh
that's a secret shame there was an email
waiting
she has never brought that up there was
rehearsals
rented i think it was they're downtown
third street that's right but casey
didn't need to be there i don't even
think casey was coming and it was hey
not only are you single now but you're
going to be single in eight months let's
be honest yeah let's be these are all
locked in these are all my sure fire
friends with terrible personalities they
cannot keep a man nobody's understood
lizzie kaplan was not she was single at
the time but oh she's going to find
someone else's heartbeat it was all the
permanently single women
and it was four sundays every other
sunday
to rehearse i think what if her aunts
was in it i mean it was
i
that was a secret one of her aunts had
to like fly out honestly it came out on
the podcast and i was stunned to my core
i almost drove up the side of the room
right yeah i just can't be right i
should have heard about i shudder and
forgive her so i i mean it was like i
was like what's that mantra i forgive
you
i forgive my i don't forgive myself for
agreeing to it
who put the kibosh on it that's what i
need to understand there's a group text
okay it was email it was this was back
and not only are you making me rehearse
for four sundays you're making me check
my email which is the worst part of all
this yeah and uh she
for some reason it did not go to junk
my emails uh
[Laughter]
and she
in in true casey fat and casey is
someone who's like
so um
brilliantly
uh
enveloped in like a romantic notion and
by romantic i just mean like
yeah a fantasy thing and then is so
self-aware that she'll go
oh my god like we've had moments like
this before where something will happen
and you go oh my god i just said this
thing and i had no idea i'm so sorry
yeah she can catch herself she's not
delusional god no yes she'll have rome
moments of like
romanticizing something i i believe what
she what she was pitching was a genius
idea
that should be in a tv show about a
crazy bride so i was like i think you're
confusing an amazing pilot story with
your actual life
i will say dear friends i will to your
friends after her going i'm sorry this
was crazy everybody i lost my mind uh i
got in the break and you know
i did show up
at her wedding with a pop star who wore
a wedding dress so
who's the crazy one in this scenario
i haven't apologized for that and you
won't no i don't see that happening
listen we were all making moves i i was
stunned just so you know i do think
she is deeply repentant about that
because she's never spoken about it
other than on a oh did i bring that or
did i bring it up i've never i've never
i have never heard i almost drove off
the side of the road when i heard that i
was like what
here's what i will say because i was the
maid of honor so i feel like i had some
responsibility and i actually want you
to know
there was nobody else
co-signing
but i think she with good intention
wanted to dazzle you with our flash mob
i mean you could i think i needed to be
surprised
it wasn't going to work she started a
new email account a burner phone to even
organize this this was the idea was to
surprise and dazzle and what i will say
is that at casey wilson's wedding
the only problem i had with it
beside the fact that your speech was so
funny it made me jealous
um did we get sued yes we did
uh
i just remember you talking about making
a movie together and you're like dude
this person heard the ass backwards yeah
we'll do that later but yeah uh it was
like
did this person sue us yes they did
uh asking a question that the i love it
when people ask questions that no one
was gonna ask and just interviews
themselves yes was i angry yes i was
was i frustrated absolutely
i love that you made your monologue a
dialogue with yourself you need to
listen you need to be insane the one
problem i had with her wedding was that
i didn't get to
steal the show by dancing to single
ladies i mean and here's the thing i
believe there's a world in which that
email went out a week before
and it could have landed when i said
force oh oh yeah the single ladies email
like had that email arrived in your
inbox a week before the wedding and by
the way do whatever you want just it's
going to come on
yes and you're going to have this moment
you know and it'll be really fun just so
every all the single guys there know who
the singer is
but well they put us all on the table so
we already were like you were like half
in sunlight we were at i was at the kids
table why they put all the single people
at one table i never understand put us
with the adults who no single adults
yeah no we i had we had to apply
sunscreen
frequently sure yeah sure yeah it was it
was me
lizzy kaplan and then the cast of happy
endings right that weren't married
right
i do think though there's a world in
which that email could have gone over
and like daniel
had it not been so far in advance it was
the table that like just to make sure
none of these people get in the photos
in case they get canceled one day
these are like the wild cards yeah we
got to be like at the wild card table
oh my god the undesirables right and
then a pop star in a wedding dress
oh my god don't give single people
guests i am a big proponent single yeah
okay you don't want a plus one a
girlfriend of mine had a wedding and a
nice and she said you can only bring a
plus one if you've met the person's
parents said i love you and been on
vacation together which i thought was
really good very fair so the person i
was with for two months i was like i
love you want to go on a vacation
then i was like does the destination
wedding count as a vacation i feel like
i'm going to get you on a formality but
yeah i don't want i wouldn't want random
randos in the wedding photo you look
back 20 years later you're like who's
that right i think the pharmaceutical
sales rep you had a one-night stand but
would you if you were single be okay
showing up without a plus one
yeah cause all the guys i did are
sketchy and embarrassing and their wives
might be there right right right
no i
i bring girlfriends yeah like you did
for casey's wedding yeah i bring
girlfriends that could steal the show if
they decide to sing right i bring talent
you do i pray i bring vendors i
i bring
an that you couldn't afford and if we
just get a couple drinks in her you
might get the best show of your life
but yeah i try to bring
girlfriends only because i just feel
like very smart i don't want to be with
some guy that makes it about him and
then i can't very smart or gets jealous
or does something mature or shitty or
has fucked someone at the wedding like
my whole thing is when you go to someone
else's wedding
your skirt comes down to the knee your
hands are not out
you're not wearing body glitter or any
kind of shimmers you are not wearing
white or beige unless instructed
otherwise and you bring someone who is
very low risk if you have a plus one i
love this whitney this is important this
is a psa this is not worth your day
information if i can see your upper
thigh
yeah or the wrinkles in your breast
implants yeah you have got to i i i want
to go full magic castle you know there's
a yeah yeah yeah in l.a you have your
shoulders out and about there's a place
of magic castle where if you're not if
you're wearing jeans or or anything
that they deem too casual they just give
you a jacket like a dead person's blazer
and yearly feels that way yes and you're
wearing some like tommy bahama like
khakis and that's on youtube and like
dress shoes you're wearing like uncle
vanya's costume yes correct oh my god i
appreciate that and honestly that was a
note for me because i think i played it
a little fast and loose with with my
some of my wedding attire and i'm taking
this end that's like some fearless
feedback that i think
i've needed
i think sometimes i'm using it as an
opportunity to like hoe it up a little
bit you're the drummer you're not the
singer got it it's not your day got it
it's not your day if you want to bust
out a poppy lip god speed yeah but it
better be with a madewell burlappy type
wrap dress got it and i feel like you're
going like lip or eye but not both
earrings or necklace not both not both
yes yes
skirt or tube top not both
pick one you get you get to have one get
to have one one lashes or lips one not
both
no it's not it's it is georgia it's
important for me it is you are
background
backgrounds don't background people
don't get to wear red
okay so i just want you to know speaking
of casey's wedding and this is the last
thing i'll say because again i think i'm
bleeding all over your furniture okay
this i think i'm now a free bleeder i
have big
those people are out there i think i'm
one of them
um because men don't stay on chairs from
restoration hardware but menstrual cups
do an incredible job but they only can
do what they can do
you know so yeah
um but i will and you have not sat in
the bathtub and excavated your
uterine lining so i will say that i'm
taking this feedback because just so you
know i said to casey as the maid of
honor to be clear this was not feedback
that was this was unsuccessful
and it accidentally applied it it
accidentally
attacked you it's hitting pretty hard
actually because
i don't know if you'll remember but at
casey's wedding i was a maid of honor as
well as her best friend amanda sovik
from
um high school and we were in the same
dresses as the rest of the gals but i
said to casey how will people know that
that we're maids of honor
we need to stand away from the fray
we're not
the handmaids don't dress like the
martha like we're just different and
we're better correct and how do we and
we've frankly done that across totally
yes
you know i'm not saying i want this but
it is what it is i'm not wearing the
dress from j crew let's talk
turk and she was like i want them all
the dresses to be the same i'm like okay
but again how will people know
that i'm in charge yes
what are we saying that i'm the best so
i then said what are we seeing what are
we saying here what are we saying
if i can't be the authority figure that
gets more respect than i deserve here
what are we saying is this a lawless
land yeah where's the hierarchy yeah
because there's a pop star getting way
more attention than she deserves we need
to all understand who we are in the past
um
groups always need an alpha absolutely
and i'm worried that we're all wearing
the same dress and people aren't going
to know so should we discuss hats well
what we came to was
a crown
i
guess you don't remember it but amanda
and i were a floral crown now did i
ask for it yes i did
you know and did you force casey to pay
for it yes i did that that's a part of
her floral bill
okay
and so we were crowned and then
and all the irony is that a woman in a
flower crowd at the wedding i take the
least seriously of anyone there
i'm like oh that bitch isn't i wasn't i
didn't trust her i demanded it
and it was important that the other
bridesmaids knew too we wanted it to
sort of um
be evocative of jesus christ you know
who were a crown because those are the
type of sacrifices i made so
we were our crowns and a lot of people
had feelings about it you know and i was
like yeah you have feelings about it
because you don't have a crown mm-hmm i
would i would too if i was in it yeah
get it and so gorgeous her flowers were
beautiful and it looks great
you know and i know in all the pictures
like it's pulling focus
as it's intended to do as that's the
purpose of the question to befuddle
confuse intimidate and distract now i
don't know if you know this but people
had a lot to say casey had allowed to
say she got us her crowns
other bridesmaids are upset you know i
trying to calm them down
blah blah blah blah blah but you weren't
picked to be the maid of i wish you
could have a crime so what's going on
with you what did you do in your past to
get here this is more of an award than a
crown so what's going on with you that
you don't have one absolutely take that
question those are this is your
consequence this is a this is a a
growth opportunities for you you're on a
growth edge why don't you deserve why
don't you have one
you know but i can't dim my own life
you know
i won't
i will not make myself smaller for you i
will make myself bigger in the form of
roses ferns and limelight
so
lo and behold
everybody had something to say about our
crowns and
um
i mean
they had a lot to say about me demanding
they call me your highness but i gave i
gave that up i did i did accommodate
that yeah i wasn't happy yeah riding up
on a horse i decided the carriage and
the horse don't need to happen so
afterwards i did make them bow
listen the joke was on them
because the wedding photos
with me and amanda and our crowns and
casey
turned out so beautifully
that a little uh rag called martha
stewart weddings
asked to put that photo on their cover
is that why she was sent to jail
[Laughter]
for depicting emotional abuse at a
wedding
again i
i hear what you're saying i hear the
notes you're giving but i also
want the women out there to know that
yes it's the bride's death and you're a
queen okay but
if you have a special position a
position of honor mm-hmm you know i'm
calling
it
a maid
[Applause]
you're the cleaning lady of honor it's
this act of service but an honorable one
uh-huh okay and i'm not just a maid no
those are those other ladies
the maids
i'm the honor part you're the main part
okay this is just this is just
i don't make these rules
the greeks did it
this is our ancestors yeah this is
apollo made this
i don't know i'm just carrying on the
tradition that women can be superior to
other women that's how queens happen
listen again i i don't even like it but
it is what it is yeah yeah you know yeah
yeah i don't want the these bugs in my
hand yeah see all of it so
but if you are in the wedding party that
is a different story okay it is your job
now we're getting granules better than
you've ever looked if you were the plus
one of someone that is coming to a
wedding and you don't know anyone there
you are wearing lane bryant
you are wearing the simplest witness
most j crew shit whitney i would never
a stripe is fine
but you cannot
be a thot at someone else's wedding i
have i do think that a few times i've
definitely
you know i've shown too bright i but as
a maid of honor that is your job it is
it is your job but i'm looking back on a
few of the looks i've put together
through the years you know as a maid of
honor just as just as a
guest as a guest well
but again i've been given this body in
this face i mean we have the same one so
you i've been given the same body in the
same base and i'm inspired actually
actually just you have
inspired me
you know what's weird i feel like we've
gotten prettier as we've gotten older we
definitely we're so much prettier
definitely yeah we are like benjamin
buttoning i don't know what's going on
can i tell you i thought that we were
i thought yes we grew into our face
and the because we were in our 20s we
were very confident and very assertive
and that's ugly on a young person but we
grew into our personalities and our bone
structures yes here's what i'm going to
say about women aging i've
loved aging
i've never
in my opinion looked better i i've never
looked better i've never felt better
i've never felt more comfortable and
there's something and i am dating the
youngest man i've ever dated yeah and i
thought he was a
field team and he
i truly was like oh that's a great
looking landscaper
did when i treated him according to your
a teenager
i truly did i'm going to have to do some
real work on how i treat him he is a big
fan of yours okay great yeah even that
hurts even more yeah yeah big fan he's
like i watch new girl just for her or
something yeah yeah you were a doctor a
new girl yes yes
and um i feel like we
yeah i just feel like we look we grew
into our faces yes absolutely we've
never looked better
look and i'm not i've never been better
never been better never been
prettier inside and out yeah never been
i mean look i had the fat removed from
my under eyes fine but you're younger
than me i'm in my 40s now i'm 41
i forget but i'm 41. and i'm still
bleeding up a storm
your uterus is as young as it's ever
been jesus
um but i i love it
i'm like i love it i'm like in i used to
never
look at myself naked and i used to never
if i was in a bathing suit walk
like i didn't want my thighs to jiggle
or like touch when i was walking i like
am so into my body you should be you
should i want to see more of it but i
have like like um okay i do oh then let
me borrow some of your your handkerchief
tops yeah i'll give you some remember
those what were those some of your mesh
that's a really deep cut
remember those things we were there was
like a handkerchief it was like just a
triangle and then your sides show in
your back completely back or back maybe
had like one string i had one that was a
butterfly it was just a sequined
butterfly that covered your tits in a
little bit and i wore it every time i
went to the club
like i love talking to you and like
casey where because there's this you
know grace who's gone because they have
um the next generation of assistants and
workers they like leave at seven
wow they don't text on weekends they
they're like she's like i'm gonna go
home the first the first day
she worked do you remember were you
there no i don't think you were there
the first day she worked i was at the
rental house
and um at like one o'clock she was like
i think i'm gonna get something to eat
and i'm like oh it's a work day so what
you're gonna like deep throat a
nutrigrain bar or a kind bar a cliff bar
eating your coffee
i turn around i smell like does that
smell she's cooking in the kitchen oh
like a succotash
she was cooked like an omelet and came
over with a full meal wow that i'm like
that's that's like a sunday holiday
brunch
and that's just her monday
the level of self-care that's great to
hear the level of self-respect
no we are firing please stop with all
your advocacy it is backfiring we have
to pay internships look what you've done
i take it all back listen we have
something to learn and they have
something to learn from us too that's
correct that's correct well i guess
we'll just have to work together and be
a team god forbid um
june i i could talk to you forever i
want to and i know the fans are gonna
want to i'm gonna just say a couple
things um please buy the book represent
if you have not already to and give if
you are a guy that i know a lot of you
guys listen to this podcast and i'm
grateful and you come up to me and
you're like i learned so much about
women and i understand my daughters more
and i understand my wife more give this
to your daughter as a gift uh this is a
great birthday present christmas present
get it for the women in your life or if
you're a woman get it for yourself and
all of your friends can i give one plug
please all of them so i'll give all the
plugs but thank you for that and also
for any of the women or really any
genders out there
whitney and i talked about jorian howard
and the jane club is something we've
created together with one i've created
with one of which it works very dearly
for women that provides child care yes
and we are
services that women that our moms would
never have time to drive to all of them
yes i have provided a lot of the books
in the library yes you did now our
physical space is still shut down but we
in the pandemic pivoted and have an
incredible digital community and talking
today about like women who were in
competitive positions and you and i were
in our still our industry still are
but you really taught me early on about
like community being so much more
important than any of our individual
success and how men are actively profit
off of us competing each other pitting
each other against each other
everybody rises when you support each
other absolutely and the jane club is a
space where that happens all the time
and so if folks are curious head to
jainclub.com and we have a special code
for your listeners
good for you
which if you type in
we have an unbelievable community
platform it is the social media
experience you wish you had on facebook
it is everything and more and if you
type in good for you at gene club.com
you can get half off your first month
wait no one's gonna say trump 2024
it's not
there's no trump 2024 memes so we do a
lot of
community sort of curating and we do a
lot of facilitating on all of our
channels to keep it a really respectful
wonderful joyful
hilarious space so
that's a plug for jane club because it's
changed my life
um and it's just so much fun and if i
may
i also believe that the jane club
provides these
interviews with people these symposiums
these talks the type of guests that you
guys procure is like
everything you want out of the ted talks
but you're like i don't need to know why
praying mantis is killed like i don't
need these esoteric ted talks about like
i think how architecture has evolved to
be more like the jungle like i don't
that's interesting but it's not going to
change my life and
uh these talks are like
you know to me the biggest issue the
biggest most important word to me right
now is like access like having access to
the wisdom and this is why i started a
podcast i was like i guess there's just
something in our
blood as elders to pass on wisdom it's
like you you know and that just we've
been so disconnected for so long and
um
we have a lot of wisdom it's weird to
say that that's true and so for this
next generation or current generation to
oh i'm not on the home page that's weird
um uh jainclub.com i will be filing some
complaints uh these talks like i did one
that was beautiful and so well attended
and then to thank you
god
j i feel like jane fonda and i were dory
was i was like how did i do how did i do
numbers-wise and she's like jane fawn is
a little higher but you're pretty i was
like yes um
and i'm sitting there talking to these
people they're asking me questions i'm
telling them i'm like
this is so valuable
that people get to in real time talk to
me ask me anything they want and i'm
just telling them every single thing
i've learned i don't know how else to
get this to these women like iron man
whoever it is young people like it's
it's a miracle it's listen thank you for
doing that by the way and all of the
james were obsessed
with it i guess i'll talk to dorian
women for their work um but
people wonder like why is facebook toxic
why do i hate going on there um and you
really do assume that like you're just
signing onto facebook and it's free
right but like these platforms of course
are not free and you are being sold ads
and there is a
very well functioning machine behind it
our platform is a paid platform but the
other thing i'll say is that we don't
deny anyone access who can't afford it
promo code we have a promo code for you
all but also if that promo code still
makes it inaccessible please know you
can sign on a sliding scale we do that
and we're able to do that because so
many of our other janes pay more we are
able to um sustain ourselves with all of
our sliding scale jains who are
completely anonymous um and our angel
chains are also anonymous and we do that
really intentionally i want to be an
angel jane well you can be an angel jane
and i will make that happen okay thank
you but um it's a really beautiful
community platform and uh i just thought
that somebody walked away i feel like i
got more out of
being one of the speakers than anyone
got out of it because like the questions
these people were asking me like
i was able to like sort out a lot of my
own like oh yeah like and i yeah
and i also believe that it's a safe
space to not i'm just gonna say this and
it's i know it's not gonna come out
elegant and and people are gonna have
feelings about it but i do feel like
there's a lot of like bullying within
feminist groups of you have to be this
kind of feminist and being a feminist or
a strong woman means this and this and
this you have to dress a certain way and
act a certain way and
the jain club i felt very able to say
things
like and take it early take what you
like and leave the rest but
if you don't want to be
i feel like there's a lot of pressure on
women now that's like do i have to be a
ceo of a fortune 500 company like do i
have to direct movies if i don't want to
like this pressure
to be excel in a way that might not be
what you want well i think what if i
just want to be a forest and also what i
think that does sometimes is we also
completely devalue and this is really
the spirit of the jane club and why we
started this
the invisible labor that women are doing
so
i
we believe firmly that if you walk into
the space the digital space right now
and
you are taking care of your children
full time that that's work yes and it
might be it might be
an honor it might be really secret of be
a founder of an app no if you don't want
but by the way that work is just as
valuable that's right that's valuable
work that's right you're taking care of
your parents as a caretaker that's a
full-time job work you know you're a
domestic laborer doing housekeeping in
someone's home all work is on earth
that drives me nuts because everyone
like there's this new thing where direct
women directing movies is the ultimate
thing it's like they have 300 people
helping them
that's harder than raising two children
and i've had a lot of struggle with when
i get offered direct movies i i kind of
don't like it that much unless it's like
the perfect thing unless it was like all
of our friends and it was a
collaborative effort and i was just the
person that had to like be a bitch every
now and then or demand you know whatever
a bigger budget like i can do all that
but there's this thing where it's like
i'll get offered movies to direct and
it's like i'm a bad feminist if i don't
say it's like no the whole point of this
is to not do things you don't want to do
because you have to well and also i
think it's like that i the jane club and
i firmly believe it too like really
believes that if you if we just simply
recreate patriarchal and capitalist
systems
then we're not moving the ball forward
like what i what i want is to feel like
i'm actually valuable in our culture
without accomplishing anything
actually
says the person that started three
businesses wrote a book and uh
and also like i'm raising children and
that's and that's and i have
i took care of my father when he was
sick that's one of my greatest
accomplishments that's right that's
doing this podcast and obviously this
podcast but there are i'm trying to for
myself really like decolonize my
relationship with capitalism and not
define yourself through your
accomplishments or productivity for me
my self-esteem has always been so linked
to my quote-unquote productivity which
really lies in the hands of others
my entire career but
my self-esteem is in the right place and
i am right with myself and whatever you
believe god the universe who gives a
shit um when i can kind of do nothing
for a day and just take care of myself
and not feel guilty or like i'm falling
behind or feel like i have to put it on
well because what happens is that
there's a system that we're all a part
of and ultimately like it's
when we fail within it we assume that's
our personal failure and we don't look
at the infrastructure and the system
that's like set up no one so that we
succeeded in this situation no one could
have succeeded i mean that here's the
other thing about about movies because i
i do think it's important and i did i
think i said this maybe in the thing of
when people want to
like
for clickbait or for just their own
histrionic desires or their own selfish
motives or to like feel like a martyr or
silence breaker or something when
they're when when actually they're just
like not
um educated on the actual data of it
so to me when actresses only actresses
want to say like only
six percent of movies were directed by
women this is it
okay
that is true but you're not factoring in
all the women that were offered movies
and they passed because they can't go to
new zealand for eight months
so
you a lot of these studios will go offer
to a woman without any child care on set
they have two children which to me moms
are the best at being bosses because
they can do 50 things at once chaos is
not weird to them
half of your job as a director and ep is
to just deal with people's emotions and
tantrums which usually is just low blood
sugar like the moms when i'm working
with a mom on a set
they are able to diffuse every conflict
with like do you need a water do you
want a sandwich you just need why don't
you go back to trial and you take a nap
and it's solved like and they can handle
like they can do multitask in a way that
most people can't
and take nothing personally and they're
like breastfeeding and there's shit on
their head like nothing bothers them
right and so um
but also
that to me is a very frustrating thing
for people to focus on because i would
like to see the data of the amount of
women that were offered directing jobs
and had to say no because the system is
not conducive to a mother so to me why
do we have a 2 000 salami spread that
nobody's eating and not a paid
babysitter for the day well at yes and i
will add to that that women are having
children later and later and that's a
trend that's only going to continue so
like we're not having we're spending our
20s investing in our careers and our 30s
and a lot of times the time the year
we're having our first child yeah is the
year we'll probably make the most money
we'll ever make
those years are like this well and then
we wonder why women aren't directing
films and we wonder like why aren't they
where is this the same reason they don't
play football because they know if you
have to put a helmet on it's probably a
bad idea right right but there's no
that's why i get really frustrated and
i've refused to like do panels and
conversations around like oh june what's
your tip on how you wrote a book and
started a company and have a career how
did you do it i'm like don't fucking ask
one person ask the studio system
because
it's just a conversation and a a slogan
of like having it all and being able to
balance it because until
these
power structures are willing to say
we're gonna do a reasonable work day
family hours you can breastfeed whenever
the fuck you want all of that stuff
unless we're really willing to honor
that women are taking care of small
children
they just are
which is more the reason to hire them
yes but they're because directing a
movie is taking care of small children
what happens is is employers
when men have children assume they'll
work harder
when women have children assume they'll
work less
and they'll just work smarter
of course but that's the motherhood tax
that a lot of us pay and the other piece
of it is like
we're not just taking care of small
children many of us and you've been in
this position whitney are also taking
care of our parents
so it's like at both ends of life
there's this labor right and then
there's you half of the nbc stick come
amazon i wrote from emory icu and like
icus you know and
you know to me i go the person in the
hospital the icu dealing with drama
that's going to be a better artist on
the like that's not a reason to say
don't do this job it's like
great let's use that you know because
life is then what you have to pay for is
the child care is that full-time nanny
is the
you know hours that's what that's where
the power structures have to recognize
it's like this is what comes with that
writer's room schedules and movie
schedules were made for men that hate
their wives yes it's let's start at 10
a.m every woman i know is like i dropped
my kid off at 7 45 i had to just kill
time for it took having all these women
in in my writers rooms that were moms
going like can we start at 8 30
i was like why do we start at 10. that
is so weird it's like we dropped our
kids off and we're just like in the
parking running errands and right but
then no we have to mentally be here
until seven and are missing but at 2 45
we need to pick them up so what if we
just work from 8 30 to 3
or our kids could come here after school
which would be so cool to have them
watch their mom working and doing a cool
job and being respected and and i
struggle with this a lot but holding
like the the big picture yeah and and
like the big idea and then the fucking
knit i mean that's what the that that
book is about too
by the way
you just just delete your nudes delete
your name pretty much your heads
it's also like yeah we want more women
in office okay but how
and but what about kids and but what
about pictures and but what about the
stuff
now i also believe
in
the both end of like you can work from
the outside and try to tear the system
down i'm heading more in that direction
or you can get inside and then do your
work
from the inside and both are valuable
both need to have the tear down is not
just you know two women that have some
power influence in what we do and that
gets a higher etc it's also like
you know we are at this amazing moment
where
if if we call out people shitty behavior
people stop patronizing them i mean it's
just
it's there's it's a little more
democratic than we thought like people
don't want to watch shit made by bad
people anymore they don't want to watch
things that uh make them feel dirty or
like the the the spell has been broken
that's true and people don't want to
give their money to people that are
dickheads or don't do things in a or do
things in an untoward way and it
reflects
also the most important thing because
hollywood is a business it's a money
business it's it's stock it's wall
street
they don't make movies because they want
to be progressive or they want to be
inclusive they make movies if the uh
they make more if they make money and
are good and the bottom line that i
always have to explain to people is i'm
not saying hire diverse because it's the
right thing to do it will make this
project better
so go go do the right thing for the
wrong reason you know what i'm saying
use your selfish motive and your
mercenary tactics to go oh no this is
actually going to make the project
better no they didn't make a second
black panther because they like felt bad
and didn't want to be racist it made a
ton of money because it was fucking
great we saw that in the theater
together i don't know if you remember
that by the way
this has happened a couple of times
this is happening by the way the arc
light i mean i hope it reopens but like
the arc light case i used to always say
like the lobby of the arclight is a
minefield
it is of agents you fired x's that
cheated you never know what it is who
you're going to see
better general meetings
ready i have never put more effort into
my parents than when i go see a casual
movie at the arclight like 4pm tits or i
dress for the offline the way you dress
for weddings
the tits are out the lips are lined the
lashes are blue
i've gotta you will see the only time
you'll ever see me in a bump it is in
the arc light lobby i've been teased i'm
using the
little makeup sponge that uses
yeah
that's it
the number of jobs i believe i've lost
showing up to the arc blade yeah i made
that mistake early on in my career of
just like i'm going to see a movie like
what whatever could happen
no you're going to audition for a movie
that hasn't been written yet
you truly are
like
consider this a showcase
you know and correct consider the banter
you do and like every interaction you
not a lobby this is a runway this is the
up front i mean when i say i wear a
thong to the arc light i wear a thong
and he the only place you'll find me in
heels is in the arclight yes i'm like
that's danny boyle yeah you'll see
everyone there
whitney
please do not bring that nightmare back
jesus why are the
books 55
whitney i don't know but i am truly
worried that my menstrual okay
i am i have a fistula
june i am so obsessed with you uh there
will be much much more information in
the bio if uh if we're running over it
too fast janeclub.com
yeah it's not edu
org
no i have a speech on there it's not edu
there's no edu involved.gov maybe
eventually.gov um i love you i love you
i am these very awkwardly how did this
get made is easily the funniest podcast
just know that it pains me to say that
and you have a new podcast with the
great jessica sinclair which i'd love to
have you on
i mean if you're willing but i don't
know we have so much guys i will be
auditioning for the co-host position do
you feel like we just scratched the
surface we did but i hope you will do
this again uh absolutely i hope you will
give me more of your emotional labor and
um
uh dude we have a
when we schedule the next one like plan
it around your dimensions i do have one
good week a month
if you get murdered i will be the number
one suspect
because their your blood is all over my
body
i love you guys don't write elephants
the great
june
diane
[Music]